Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Oh, hier hat es viele Rentiere.
Schau mal, überall.
Und ganz viele Junge.
Schau dir das an.
Hm? Schau mal,
das ist wohl der Platzhirsch.
Ähm ...
* Sie lacht. *
Ich glaube,
die haben sowieso keine Angst.
Das war eine Yoga-Masterclass.
Du, aber, Junge ...
Junge, come on. Hm?
Komm. Hopp.
Ich bin unterwegs im hohen Norden.
Ein Sehnsuchtsort für viele von uns.
Auch für mich.
Wir besuchen
Schweizerinnen und Schweizer,
die hier oben
ihre neue Heimat gefunden haben.
Ich bin unterwegs durch Finnland,
Schweden und Norwegen
und möchte rausfinden,
was die Faszination
am Leben im hohen Norden ist.
Mitternachtssonne und Polarlichter -
die Natur hier oben
ist überwältigend.
Und sie bietet viel Platz
für Mensch und Tier.
Das nennt sich "pimpla"
auf Schwedisch.
Eisfischen.
Die Finnen sind die Kurligsten.
Aber auch immer bereit
für einen Spass.- Schon?
Dann bist du ein guter Finne.
- Ja.
In diesem Film
besuchen wir neue Auswanderer.
Aber auch solche, die wir
aus "Auf und davon" schon kennen:
Mäx und Yasmine Hensler.
Es gibt Neuigkeiten.
Ich bin mit den Kindern während
der Schulzeit in der Schweiz.
Du gehst
zurück in die Schweiz mit ihnen.
Unsere Reise bringt uns
an ganz unerwartete Orte.
Jetzt geht es in meine Luxussuite.
Wir können sie uns anschauen.
Ein kleines Zimmerchen.
Wah.
Du musst einfach sagen,
es schmecke gut. "Mmh, so lecker."
Wir sind bei grossen Momenten dabei.
* Er spricht norwegisch. *
"Auf und davon" XXL - eine Reise
durch wilde Natur, Wind und Wetter.
Mitten im Orkan
machen wir ein Picknick.
"Auf und davon" im hohen Norden.
Schön, seid ihr dabei.
* Entspannte Musik *
Gut, du kannst gleich aufmachen.
- Ja.
Weit oben in Finnland
startet meine Reise.
Sind das alle?
- Ja, sollten es sein.
Der St. Galler Markus Brülisauer
lebt hier mit 33 Schlittenhunden.
* Pfeifen *
Papis.
Das ist morgens immer so.
Da rennen sie 10 Min. rum,
bis die grösste Energie raus ist.
Aska! Aska.
Danach kommen sie wieder runter.
Dann ist wieder Ruhe.
Vor drei Jahren
wanderte Markus hierher aus.
Zusammen
mit seiner deutschen Partnerin Josi.
Ganz frisch dabei ist ihr Sohn Aaro.
Ihre Hunde halten sie
in einem grossen Rudel
mit möglichst viel Auslauf.
Haben die Hunde euch hierhergebracht?
Ja, bei mir ist das definitiv so.
In der Schweiz wäre das
nie möglich in diesem Rahmen.
So viele Hunde
auf einer solchen Fläche -
das könnte man nicht bezahlen.
Ich habe ja zwei Jahre
in der Schweiz gelebt,
bevor wir ausgewandert sind.
Die Schweiz ist wunderschön.
Landschaftlich ein Traum.
Aber es ist halt sehr eng.
* Knurren *
Hier oben haben wir diesen Luxus,
dass wenig Menschen auf einer
sehr grossen Fläche Natur leben.
Wir sind uns bewusst,
dass das ein Luxus ist.
Und was für ein Luxus,
den Josi und Markus hier haben:
60 ha Land, inkl. Seeanstoss.
Wir sind weit nördlich in Finnland,
schon über dem Polarkreis, in Ivalo.
Neben den Hunden haben
Josi und Markus noch mehr Tiere.
So.
Jetzt kommen noch die Schweine dran.
Sie wollen sich so gut wie möglich
selber versorgen.
Die Wildschweinchen
haben sie erst seit drei Tagen.
Haben sie schon Namen?
- Das Männchen heisst Obelix.
Nein.
Der,
der immer alle Wildschweine isst.
Genau.
- Ist das ein schlechtes Omen?
Nein, er überlebt.
- Ah.
Er muss ja für den Nachwuchs sorgen.
Obelix.
Wie einfach war es,
ein so grosses Grundstück zu finden?
Das man auch bezahlen kann?
Es war nicht geplant,
60 ha Land zu haben.
Das war Zufall.
Uns hätten auch 2-3 ha gereicht.
Das hat sich einfach so ergeben.
Hattet ihr einen genauen Plan,
als ihr ausgewandert seid?
Man muss ja von etwas leben.
Wir machten natürlich
einen Businessplan
und berechneten alles genau.
Das muss man,
wenn man es schaffen will.
Das hatten wir schon.
Aber wenn man dann auswandert ...
... ändert sich so viel.
Es gibt viele Rückschritte.
Da merkt man dann auch,
wer wirklich auswandern will ...
... und wer sich
eben nicht ganz sicher ist.
Beim Auswandern müssen
beide Personen 100 % dahinterstehen.
Und wenn jemand
nur 99 % dahintersteht,
funktioniert es nicht.
- Mhm.
Da geht die Beziehung kaputt
oder das Ganze klappt nicht
und man geht zurück.
Bei Markus
und seiner Partnerin Josi Habermann
scheint es aber
bestens zu funktionieren.
So gut, dass sie neben dem Auswandern
noch in ein anderes Abenteuer
gestartet sind.
Ja, guten Morgen.
Oh. Hast du auch Hunger?
Hm?
Aaro heisst ihr erstes Kind.
Er ist drei Monate alt.
In einem Arm das Baby,
in der anderen Hand das Messer.
Einhändig
ist alles immer etwas schwieriger.
Kennengelernt
haben sich Josi und Markus
auf einer grossen Schlittenhundefarm,
auf der sie beide arbeiteten.
Eigentlich ein Ferienflirt,
der dann doch etwas länger dauerte.
Markus
ist gelernter Landschaftsgärtner.
Er baut möglichst vieles selber,
wie auch das Gehege der Yaks.
Hm? Siehst du die Yaks?
Er wächst mit sehr vielen Tieren auf.
- Mhm.
Bist du das auch?
- Gar nicht.
Erstaunlicherweise ...
Ich wuchs in einer mittelgrossen
deutschen Stadt auf.
Wir lebten immer in Wohnungen.
- Du bist ein Stadtmädchen.
Ja. Aber ich fühlte mich nie wohl.
In der Jugendphase ist das natürlich
spannend und schön, aber ...
Wenn ich an Momente zurückdenke,
wo ich
nicht mit Freunden unterwegs war,
sass ich meistens am Fenster,
schaute raus und versuchte,
irgendwo Bäume zu sehen
oder Vögel zu hören und träumte.
Aber ohne mir
dessen bewusst zu sein.
Es gab einfach immer
die Sehnsucht nach mehr Ruhe.
Ich geniesse jeden Tag.
Das sage ich nicht nur klischeehaft.
Gegessen hat er schon.
Mmh, du hast Mami vollgesabbert.
Ja, ist gut.
- Eins, zwei, drei.
Gewickelt habe ich schon.
Hm? Bis später, Spatzl.
Soll ich mit denen anfangen?
Ihre Hunde sind für die beiden
Auswanderer existenziell wichtig.
Sie leben zur Hauptsache
von Hundeschlittentouren im Winter.
Aber auch im Sommer
sind ihre Hunde im Einsatz:
auf mehrtägigen Trips mit dem Kanu.
Dann versuchen wir das mal.
Baghi, komm.
Ui. Erst mal du rein, Mäuschen.
Hältst du das Boot fest?- Ja.
Eins, zwei, drei.
Die zehn Monate alte Baghira
ist zum allerersten Mal im Kanu.
Super, Baghira. Gute Maus.
Du kannst uns irgendwohin paddeln.
- Okay.
Sie scheint
ziemlich entspannt zu sein.
Super, Baghira. Siehst du?
Jetzt ist wieder spiegelglatter See.
- Megaschön.- Super, Baghira.
Gute Maus.
- Wie sie schaut.
Es habe auch schon Hunde gegeben,
die vor Aufregung
ins Wasser gesprungen seien.
Nicht jeder Hund ist ein Seehund.
Sie macht es nicht schlecht
für ihr allererstes Mal Boot fahren.
Die meisten Hunde sind verunsichert,
weil kein Land in Sicht ist.
Super, Baghi. Ja.
Kommst du mit? Du machst das so gut.
Was sein kann ... Ich merke ...
Sie hat ein paarmal aufgestossen.
Kann sein, dass ihr übel wird.
- Okay.
Wir gehen langsam zurück.
- Ja.
Damit sie
gar nicht erst in Stress kommt.
Ja, dieses Gähnen ist auch immer
ein Anzeichen für Stress.
Sie hat das so gut gemacht,
dass wir das beenden können,
bevor sie ...
* Winseln *
Jetzt fängt sie an zu fiepen.
- Also, ich gebe Gas.
Du hast das gut gemacht.
Wir fahren zurück, gell, Baghi?
Warte, Mäuschen. Hast du sie bereit?
Komm. Ja. Super.
- Wassertest bestanden.
Gut gemacht. Ich hole es nach vorne,
dann kannst du hier aussteigen.
Super. Super, Baghi.
* Jaulen *
Das ist, weil wir hier unten sind.
- Sicher?
Und Baghira ist hier unten.
Das Rudelmitglied ist nicht vor Ort.
Das ist ein krasser Sound.
* Jaulen *
Baghi, komm. Komm, wir gehen.
Super. Hopp.
Gute Maus.
Ja. Wieder an Land, gell?
Nomadic Naali heisst das Wildniscamp
von Josi und Markus.
Naali wie der Polarfuchs.
Es ist alles klein und familiär.
Ein Ferienhäuschen,
ein Stellplatz und ein Holztipi.
Es ist schon spät,
aber immer noch hell.
Im Sommer
wird es hier oben nie dunkel.
Im Winter hingegen
ist es eine ganz andere Welt.
Wir haben Josi und Markus auch
in der kalten Jahreszeit besucht.
Ah, schau mal.
- Mega.
Baut es sich auf?
- Ja, schau, es kommt von da hinten.
Vom Mond einmal rüber.
- Wow.
Über das ganze Camp.
Polarlichter
am Winterhimmel von Ivalo.
Ein faszinierendes Spektakel.
Davon kriegt man nie genug.
Egal, wie oft es kommt.
* Sanfte Musik *
März diesen Jahres.
Josi macht die Gästezimmer bereit.
Es ist Hilfe aus der Schweiz da.
Mit gutem Grund:
Josi ist hochschwanger.
Im achten Monat.
Das ist nicht mehr so einfach:
sich runterzubeugen.
Ganz kleine Alltagshandlungen,
die früher kein Problem waren,
sind jetzt schwierig.
Ich vergesse manchmal,
dass ich schwanger bin.
Dann beuge ich mich runter
und merke: "Nein, langsam."
Bald muss Josi
für eine Untersuchung ins Spital.
Das bedeutet hier oben
eine weite Reise.
Dann sind wir so weit fertig.
In drei Wochen
wäre der Entbindungstermin.
Wir bzw. das Kind
hat sich noch nicht gedreht,
es liegt jetzt also
verkehrt herum im Bauch.
Ich muss 3 1/2 Std.
zum Krankenhaus fahren,
dann versuchen wir noch mal,
es zu drehen.
Das versucht man von aussen.
Und wenn das nicht klappt,
wird ein Kaiserschnitt geplant.
Wenn das Kind bei der Geburt
nicht richtig liegt,
ist das Risiko zu gross,
dass auf der langen Fahrt ins Spital
etwas schiefgehen könnte.
Markus bereitet alles
für eine Hundeschlittentour
mit zwei Schweizer Gästen vor.
Seid ihr ready?
- Yes.
Gut. Nervös?
- Ja.
Ehrlicherweise schon.
- Das ist normal.
So.
* Jaulen und Winseln *
Nie den Schlitten loslassen.
- Okay.
Sobald die Leine gelöst wird,
nie den Schlitten loslassen.
Egal, ob ihr die Mütze verliert
oder umfällt:
nie den Schlitten loslassen.
* Spannende Musik *
Jetzt müsst ihr etwas mithelfen.
Einfach hinten mitlaufen,
auf dem steilen Stück.
Fertig? Okay, hopp.
Das Schlimmste ist jetzt vorbei.
* Spannende Musik *
So.
Perfekt.
Simone, ging alles gut?
- Ja, super. Megacool.
Nicht wahr? War gut.
Hm, ihr zwei? Gut gemacht.
Nach der Fahrt gibt es eine
heisse Suppe - mitten im Hundegehege.
Es ist megaschön.
- Der Schlitten kippte etwas,
ich wollte abstehen
und kam in den Tiefschnee.
Es ist megabeeindruckend.
Es hat mir sehr gefallen.
Das tut richtig gut, so abzufahren.
Ich bin jedes Mal neidisch,
wenn ein Schlitten rausgeht,
weil ich die Saison
gar nicht fahren kann.
Ihr dürft gerne anfangen.
- Guten Appetit.- Danke.
Josi
macht sich auf den Weg ins Spital
für
ihre Schwangerschaftsuntersuchung.
Es ist fast eine Tagesreise.
Eine Sauna ist in Finnland
nicht nur zum Schwitzen da.
Man trinkt und kocht auch darin.
Und früher gebaren die Frauen
auch in der Sauna,
weil sie warm
und halbwegs steril ist.
Uah. Wir rutschen rein.
- Wir rutschen rein.
Uah. Uah.
* Lachen *
Ich gehe kurz runter.
Oder vielleicht auch nicht.
Ah.
* Lachen *
Ich komme wieder raus.
Wie komme ich raus?
Wo soll ich dich halten?
- Ich weiss nicht.
Darf ich?
- Ja, sicher, komm.
Dafür bezahle ich.
Nein, Spass. Tschau.
Ich gehe wieder in die Sauna.
Neben der Sauna
steht ein Grillhäuschen.
Markus
bereitet eine Lachsspezialität vor.
So. Jetzt können wir ...
... ihn so ans Feuer stellen.
Dann geht es ungefähr 45 Min.
Dann können wir essen.
- Sehr gut.
Ah, cool.
* Erwartungsvolle Musik *
So.
(Josi) Hallo.
- (Alle) Hey.
Hallo.
Na? Wie geht es euch?
Wie geht es dir?
- Gut, danke. Hi.
Spätabends kommt Josi endlich
von ihrem Spitalbesuch zurück.
Alles gut gegangen?
- Ähm ...
Das Kind war ja verkehrt herum,
und jetzt ist es gedreht.
Der Bauch ist jetzt anders.
- Yay.
Ich hatte mich gedanklich echt schon
mit dem Kaiserschnitt angefreundet.
So,
zum geplanten Termin hinfahren ...
Jetzt geht das Warten los.
- Mhm.
Ich hoffe, dass alles klappt.
Dass ich mitkann
und dabei sein kann.
50 % aller Geburten, die von hier
kommen und nach Rovaniemi fahren,
passieren irgendwo unterwegs.
D.h., irgendwo auf dem Parkplatz
oder irgendwo im Schnee am Rand.
Aber jetzt, wo es
nicht mehr verkehrt herum liegt,
hoffe ich ... Toi, toi, toi.
* Erwartungsvolle Musik *
Mona, Kaffee?
- Megagerne.
Oha, gekleckert.
Kusi?
- Ja, gerne.
* Markus singt eine Melodie. *
Wo kam Aaro auf die Welt?
Habt ihr es ins Spital geschafft
oder war es am Strassenrand?
Gerade so.
Ne, wir haben es sogar mit
Ankündigung ins Spital geschafft,
weil er zu spät kam.
Er war zwölf Tage drüber.
Damit hat keiner von uns gerechnet.
Dann mussten wir
die Geburt einleiten lassen.
Wir machten also einen Termin
und fuhren hin.
Dann lief alles,
wie man es sich wünscht?
Nicht ganz.
- Nicht ganz.
Okay. Also eher eine schwierige ...
- Ja.
Ja, insgesamt ging es dann 26 Std.
Ich hatte kein Zeitgefühl,
aber gefühlt
war er 1 Min. auf meiner Brust
und sie brachten ihn gleich weg
auf die Intensivstation.
Weil die Geburt so anstrengend
und schwierig war, hat er ...
... Fruchtwasser
geschluckt und eingeatmet.
Er hatte Wasser in der Lunge.
Dann musste er
auf die Kinderintensivstation.
Ah, er war auf der Neonatologie.
- Ja.
Da hing er
an Schläuchen und am Gerät,
am Sauerstoffschlauch ...
Das war nicht der Anblick,
den man sich wünscht.
Wenn ihr euch für eine Hausgeburt
entschieden hättet ...
Das könnte man ja,
wenn man so weit ab liegt.
Das wäre keine gute Idee gewesen.
Nein, einer von beiden
wäre wahrscheinlich gestorben.
Aber sie rieten uns
auch von Anfang an davon ab.
Weil das hier oben,
mit den Distanzen und allem,
je nachdem
lebensgefährlich sein kann.
Und in dem Fall
wäre es genau so gewesen.
Ihr wart also lange im Spital,
weil er auf der Neonatologie war.
Wie habt ihr
das mit den Hunden gemacht?
Ich ...
Ich fuhr jeden Tag runter
und wieder rauf.
Dann haben wir ...
- Wie weit ist das?
300 km, ein Weg.
Man braucht ca. 4 Std.
Es war ja im Winter.
Es lag noch Schnee und bei seiner
Geburt gab es einen Schneesturm.
Markus
brauchte 4 Std. für einen Weg.
8 Std. Fahrt, um mich zu besuchen.
- Es war eine strenge Zeit.
Man musste halt etwas schauen.
Hey, schau mal.
- Bist du aufgewacht?
Hast du Hunger?
Oi. Oh. Hm?
- Oh.
Ja. Ja.
Ja.
- Ja. Hey? Ja?
An das neue Rudelmitglied haben sich
die Hunde schon gut gewöhnt.
* Pfeifen *
Zweimal pro Jahr gibt es
einen Fellwechsel bei den 33 Hunden.
Wenn du möchtest,
kannst du bei ihr weitermachen.
So.
Jetzt verlieren sie
die Unterwolle des Winters.
Es ist eine Erleichterung für sie,
wenn man sie in dieser Zeit
ab und zu kämmt.
Woher habt ihr eure Hunde?
- Ganz verschieden.
Ungefähr die Hälfte
ist aus zweiter Hand übernommen,
d.h. von Tierschutzvereinen,
aus illegalen Zuchtstätten ...
Ich entschuldige mich für Aska.
- Es ist Liebe.
Mit Welpen
ist es nicht immer einfach.
Sumo, den du jetzt kämmst,
ist ein Urfinne.
Der kommt von hier aus Ivalo.
Der ist von unserer Nachbarin,
quasi die Strasse runter.
Er hatte ein gutes Leben,
war ein Familienhund.
Er war sechs Jahre dort
und wuchs mit Kindern auf.
Die Familie holte sich dann Hühner
und Sumo hat alle ...
... gekillt.
- Ja.
Anschliessend entschied die Familie,
dass sie lieber Hühner wolle
und gab den Hund weg.
Dann gibt es andere Fälle
wie z.B. Nimea, die ...
Ich rufe sie mal,
vielleicht kommt sie.
Wahrscheinlich ist sie im Auslauf.
Nimi. Nimea!
Die ist ursprünglich
aus der Slowakei.
Sie kommt
aus solchen illegalen Zuchtstätten.
Sie wurde
als Vermehrerhündin missbraucht
und musste schon sehr früh
oft Würfe machen,
und die Welpen
wurden jedes Mal weggenommen.
Dann
wurde sie wieder zwangsbefruchtet.
Das war so ein Kellerverschlag.
Dort kriegte sie
eine Augenentzündung und erblindete.
Sie ist blind?- Sie sieht ca. 5 %,
schätzen unsere Tierärzte. Ja.
Umso mehr wundert es mich ...
Ca. die Hälfte der Hunde
haben eine solche Herkunft, oder?
Es wundert mich,
dass das trotzdem so funktioniert.
Das
braucht extrem viel Aufmerksamkeit.
Definitiv.
Wenn man das so sehen möchte,
ist der grösste Nachteil,
dass immer entweder Markus oder ich
hier sein müssen.
Wir sind die Hauptbezugspersonen.
Wir könnten die Hunde
nicht alleine lassen.- Heftig.
Man sucht die grosse Freiheit
und ist dann megaangebunden.
Ja, teilweise ist es so.
Für uns fühlt es sich nicht so an,
weil wir
unseren Traumplatz gefunden haben.
Wir sind seit drei Jahren hier.
Aber langfristig
wünschen wir uns schon,
mit Aaro in die Ferien zu können,
die Familien zu besuchen ...
Wer bist du?
- Joulua.
Joulua?
- Mhm.
Joulua
heisst Weihnachten auf Finnisch.
Sie kam am 24.12. zur Welt.
Sie ist unser Weihnachtskind.
Der Weihnachtsmann
kommt ja aus Finnland.
Joulupukki.
- Joulupukki. Genau.
Das heisst so viel wie
Weihnachtsbock.- Weihnachtsbock.
Jeder Ort streitet sich darum,
wo genau er herkommt.
Aber er ist von hier.
Hey. Hoi. Joulua.
Für mich ist es Zeit,
um weiterzureisen.
Wenn ich euch
in zehn Jahren wieder besuche,
wie viele Pfoten und Füsse
wohnen dann hier?
Was denkst du?
- Gute Frage. Mehr Hunde ...
... wahrscheinlich nicht.
- Nein.
Wir wollen relativ klein bleiben,
um den Hunden gerecht zu werden.
Sicher nicht so viele Kinder
wie Hunde.
Hoffentlich nicht. Bitte.
Alles Gute.
- Vielen Dank.
Schön, dass du da warst, Mona.
- Tschüss.
Hey, tschau. Lachst du?
Ja, super. Tschüss.
- Tschüss.- Tschau.
* Entspannte Musik *
Ich fahre Richtung Schweden.
Dort erwartet mich
eine Auswandererfamilie,
die wir
schon aus "Auf und davon" kennen.
Bis ich ankomme, dauert es aber noch.
400 km liegen vor mir.
* Entspannte Musik *
Ah, schau jetzt. Hier kommt er her.
Offenbar kommt Santa Claus hierher,
aus Lappland.
Irgendwo hier vorne
ist anscheinend sein Zuhause.
Wir schauen mal, ob er zu Hause ist.
Oder?
Hm?
Okay. Bei uns wohnt der Samichlaus ja
in einer kleinen Waldhütte.
Aber hier sieht es anders aus.
Santa Claus scheint
ein geschäftstüchtiger Kerl zu sein.
Wow.
Im Sommer ist hier tote Hose.
Aber im Winter
stehen Touristen bis zu 5 Std. an
für einen Handshake
mit dem Weihnachtsmann.
Santa Claus. Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you too.
Einer meiner Elfen
hat mir geflüstert,
dass du aus der Schweiz bist.
- Yes.
Ich spreche ein bisschen Deutsch.
Bist du der echte Weihnachtsmann?
- Natürlich bin ich der echte.
Du hast im Fernsehen wahrscheinlich
andere Weihnachtsmänner gesehen,
aber die sind fake.
Der Coca-Cola-Weihnachtsmann
macht z.B. "Ho, ho, ho".
Aber ich mache:
"He, he, he, he, he".
Big difference.
- Big difference.
Auf Finnisch heisst du Joulupukki.
- Joulupukki.
* Er singt ein finnisches Lied
über Weihnachten. *
Joulupukki.
- Joulupukki.
Ich habe gelesen,
dass du verheiratet seist.
Nein, nein.
Miss Santa Claus und ich
sind nur sehr gute Freunde.
Sie sorgt für mich.
Sie macht guten Haferbrei
zum Frühstück.
Sie macht deine Wäsche,
bürstet deinen Bart ...- Ja.
Genau. That's true.
Aber verheiratet seid ihr nicht.
- No. No.
Das ist sehr wichtig.
- Ja.
Wir sind sehr gute Freunde,
aber nicht verheiratet.- Gut.
Der Zivilstand des Samichlaus ist
geklärt: Sie sind nur gute Freunde.
Okay.
What a pleasure meeting you
up here in Lapland.
Thanks for your visit.
Habe ich beim Händeschütteln
nicht einen Hochzeitsring
an seinem Finger gespürt?
* Entspannte Musik *
Oh, hier hat es viele Rentiere.
Schau mal, überall.
Und ganz viele Junge.
Schau dir das an.
Hm? Schau mal,
das ist wohl der Platzhirsch.
Ähm ...
* Sie lacht. *
Das war eine Yoga-Masterclass.
Du, aber, Junge ...
Junge, come on. Hm?
Komm. Hopp.
Hey.
Ui. Schau, die kämpfen.
Schau mal. Hast du das gesehen?
Die zwei.
Wow.
Jetzt realisiere ich,
wieso es so viele Rentiere
auf einem Haufen hat:
Der Helikopter treibt sie zusammen.
Wie ich später erfahre, ist der Grund
dafür die Markierung der Rentiere,
die jedes Jahr stattfindet.
5 Std. unterwegs durch Lappland,
von Ivalo bis runter an die Grenze
zwischen Finnland und Schweden.
Der Fluss trennt die beiden Länder.
Gerade auf der anderen Seite
liegt Övertornea,
die neue Heimat
der Auswandererfamilie Hensler.
Wir haben sie in der neunten Staffel
von "Auf und davon" begleitet.
Familie Hensler: Ich glaube,
wir erinnern uns alle an den Moment,
in dem Mäx nach einer langen Fahrt in
seinem neuen Zuhause angekommen ist
und vor lauter Freude
für einen kurzen Moment vergass,
auf seine Katze aufzupassen.
* Erwartungsvolle Musik *
* Jauchzer *
* Er lacht. *
Scheisse. Aisha!
Aisha. Aisha, komm.
Das gibt es gar nicht,
dass die jetzt abhaut.
Komm runter, Mädchen. Es ist kalt.
* Lustige Musik *
* Miauen *
Verdammt.
Aisha
bleibt die ganze Nacht auf dem Baum.
Mäx Henslers
erster Kontakt mit Schweden
ist darum der mit der Feuerwehr.
Gut. Alles gut. Ich bin's.
Alles gut.
Yes!
Einsiedeln, Kanton Schwyz.
Hier lebte Familie Hensler
vor ihrer Auswanderung.
Mäx arbeitete als
selbstständiger Projektleiter viel -
bis zur kompletten Erschöpfung.
Ich bin nicht so stark wie du.
Ich kann.
- Du kannst das, ich weiss.
Ich gründete damals
eine eigene Firma
für die Beratung von Supply Chain
und Entry Management usw.
Ich habe international
sehr viel erlebt.
Bis ich vor anderthalb Jahren
ein heftiges Burnout hatte.
Er war sehr angespannt.
Es brauchte nicht viel,
bis er explodierte.
Unausstehlich.
- Unausstehlich. Wirklich.
In der Krise merkte Mäx,
dass er mehr vom Leben möchte.
Also wanderte die Familie Hensler
in den hohen Norden von Schweden aus.
Im Winter 2017.
Hoi, Schatzi.
Wir haben es geschafft. Juhu.
Lauszapfen. Hey.
Yeah.
- Du hast keine Socken an.
Hey, Kimi.
Das ist alles deines, Janne.
Alles zusammen.
Du kannst überall spielen.
Schneehaufen.
Boah.
Schau mal.
- Das Chaos.
Ach du meine Güte.
Ich bin dein Vater.
Au.
Au, meine Nase.
Auf ihrer Camping- und Ferienanlage
Norrsken Lodge
geht den Henslers
die Arbeit nicht aus.
* Klingeln *
Hej?
Hej, hej.
* Er stottert. *
I'm from the camping here.
The new owner.
* Er spricht schwedisch. *
One second. Achtung.
Hey, hast du es?
Bryan?
No, no, it's open.
Do you need the reservation?
* Er spricht schwedisch. *
Ah, tschüss.
Ich glaube,
ich habe jemanden vertrieben.
Es ist schon mehr als erwartet.
Ich hatte das Gefühl, ich hätte mehr
Zeit für mich und die Familie.
Aber ich kann gut akzeptieren,
wie es momentan ist.
Um die Kinder
kümmert sich v.a. Yasmine.
Ich muss noch ...
Janne
besucht neuerdings die Vorschule.
Janne, ich komme wieder.
* Er weint. *
Und Sam kommt auch bald, okay?
Ich komme wieder, Schatz.
Alles ist gut.
Schätzchen, ich komme wieder.
Es ist alles gut, okay?
Ist gut?
- Nein.
Hm?
Du hast hier Schule.
Du kannst nicht einfach nach Hause.
Das ist hart.
Es tut mir leid, aber es ist so.
Ich kann dich
nicht nach Hause nehmen.
Sie schauen schon, was los ist.
Die grossen Belastungen durch das
Geschäft und Familie haben Folgen:
Im zweiten Winter ihrer Auswanderung
wird die Stimmung zwischen
Yasmine und Mäx immer kühler.
Sie trennen sich.
- Hier sind die Quittungen.
Das sind die bezahlten Rechnungen
und das die Quittungen. Gut?
Ja.
Ja, wir sind getrennt.
Es ging nicht mehr.
Es war schwierig.
Die ganze Saison,
den ganzen Sommer durch ...
Ich
fühlte mich verlassen und alleine.
Ich hatte das Gefühl,
es liege alles auf meinen Schultern.
Ich machte mir vielleicht
falsche Vorstellungen.
Dadurch entfremdeten
und verloren wir uns.
Ich musste irgendwie ...
Ich musste etwas verändern,
sonst wäre es nicht gegangen.
Es ist eine Scheisssituation.
Wir hingen in der Luft. Ich v.a.
Es kam von seiner Seite,
nicht von meiner.
Trotz verletzter Gefühle
machen Yasmine und Mäx
zusammen weiter -
für das Geschäft und die Familie.
Die zwei kleinen Schätze
sind das wert.
Sie haben es verdient,
dass wir als Eltern
weiter nebeneinander funktionieren.
Wir haben die Entscheidung
getroffen, hierherzukommen.
Wir haben das Ganze
an die Wand gefahren.
Aber dafür können sie nichts.
* Jubel *
Vieles ist eingestürzt, was sich
Yasmine und Mäx aufgebaut haben.
Aber keiner von beiden rennt davon.
Das zahlt sich aus.
Ein paar Monate später
finden sie sich wieder als Paar.
Oh, so einen brauchen wir.
- Nein.
In der Schweiz
wären wir jetzt wohl getrennt.
Weil dort alles einfacher wäre.
- Das könnte sein.
Hier konnten wir
nicht einfach davonlaufen.
In der Schweiz hätte jeder
irgendwo hingehen können.
Hier mussten wir einfach hier sein.
Wir mussten uns
unseren Dämonen stellen.
Die Harmonie
ist zurück auf der Norrsken Lodge.
Die Gäste kriegten von
den Turbulenzen sowieso nichts mit.
Der Betrieb lief immer bestens.
* Hoffnungsvolle Musik *
Vier Jahre ist das jetzt her.
Was sich in dieser Zeit
nicht verändert hat:
Bei Henslers läuft immer etwas.
Als ich ankomme, hat sich ein
Eichhörnchen ins Restaurant verirrt.
Aw.
Das Fenster ist zu.
Kannst du es öffnen?
Nein.
Nein. Nein.
Du musst auf diese Seite.
Ja, da. Da. Ja.
Ja, ja. Ja. Ja.
Ueh.
Juhu.
Man könnte meinen,
alles sei wie immer.
Stimmt aber nicht.
Erstens haben Henslers
einen anderen Hund
und zweitens - viel einschneidender -
lebt Yasmine mit den Kindern
den grössten Teil des Jahres
wieder in der Schweiz.
Janne und Kimi
sind nur noch in den Ferien hier.
Seit Januar sind sie in Euthal,
Kanton Schwyz, zu Hause.
Warum hast du gesagt, du gingest mit
den Kindern zurück in die Schweiz?
Wir hatten Mühe mit dem Schulsystem.
Das gefiel uns einfach nicht.
Die Erziehung der Kinder, die
hauptsächlich über die Schule läuft,
stimmte für uns nicht mehr.
Wo und wie zeigte sich das?
V.a. bei Janne.
Er ist ein Kind,
das viel hinterfragt.
Er fragt viel, warum etwas so ist.
Das war mühsam für sie.
Für die Lehrer
störte er den Unterricht.
Aber der Moment, als ihr sagtet,
dass entweder alle zurückgehen
oder ihr das separat machen müsst -
wie war das?
Das war ein Prozess.
Ein Prozess,
der nach und nach passierte.
Mit Jannes Leidensweg ...
Ich kam körperlich
auch an den Anschlag.
Man stand auf, im Winter
gab es Schneemotorradtouren,
kam nach Hause, ass kurz etwas,
machte Homeschooling,
Haushalt und die Wäsche,
dann runter mit den Gästen,
rauf mit den Kindern ...
Ich kam an den Anschlag.
Es kam nach und nach
immer mehr dazu.
Bis wir sagten:
"Jetzt machen wir den Schritt."
"Wir müssen etwas verändern."
Niemand hilft einem.
Man muss die Entscheidung treffen.
Wir diskutierten lange.
"Was machen wir?"
Entweder oder, entweder oder ...
Nach ein paar Wochen sagten wir:
"Warum 'entweder oder'?"
Wie sieht die Variante
mit 'sowohl als auch' aus?
Wie macht ihr das?
Du fehlst ja hier ...
Hier mache ich das,
was ich immer gemacht habe.
Wann bist du hier?
An Weihnachten und Neujahr.
Dann mache ich meine Dinge,
Touren usw.
In den Sportferien
und dann in den Sommerferien auch.
Sonst fliege ich
und im Sommer fahre ich hoch.
In der Zwischensaison,
April/Mai, Oktober/November,
gehe ich in die Schweiz.
Ob das die nächsten drei Jahre
so ist: keine Ahnung.
Wir haben noch andere Projekte.
Vielleicht verkaufen wir die Lodge
und machen etwas anderes.
Aber diesen Anhaltspunkt in der
Schweiz behalten wir längerfristig.
Ihre Lodge zu verkaufen
ist mehr als ein Gedankenspiel.
Sie ist nämlich
schon länger ausgeschrieben.
Bei Mäx muss immer etwas passieren.
Ich habe gelesen, dass
ein ideales Leben für die Schweden
möglichst ausgeglichen sei.
Ruhig und unaufgeregt.
Lagom nennt sich das.
Das ist nichts für Mäx.
Ich hasse Tagesgeschäfte.
Es muss etwas Spezielles laufen.
Es motiviert mich, etwas Neues
zu machen, das es noch nicht gibt.
Sobald Routine reinkommt
und immer Tagesgeschäft ist,
finde ich das nicht so toll.
Klar, das gehört dazu, aber wir
haben langfristig neue Ideen,
die wir verwirklichen wollen.
Mäx hat neben der Lodge
einen Fleischexport, ein Reisebüro
und plant die Eröffnung eines finni-
schen Restaurants in der Schweiz.
Das neuste und grösste Projekt
will er mir jetzt zeigen.
Die Spiegelung im Wasser
ist grossartig.
Das sieht man erst von hier oben.
Vorher machen wir einen Stopp bei
einem Geschäftspartner der Henslers,
wo sie gerne die Gäste der Lodge
hinschicken.
Der Geschäftspartner heisst Oskar,
ist ein Elch
und wird mit Karotten bezahlt.
Zeig mal deine Flecken.
- Jö.
Siehst du es?
Wie alt ist Oskar?
- Zehn Jahre.
Ten years?
Ist das alt für einen Elch?
Im besten Alter.
- Okay.
Der Mann, der mir das erzählt,
ist Ola Rokka.
Oskar gehört ihm.
Oskar.
* Die Kinder lachen. *
Zieh den Hut aus.
- Frisst er den Hut?
Das ist Stroh.
Ich weiss es nicht.
- Excuse me.
Sie meinten,
ich solle den Hut besser abnehmen.
Yeah.
Tauschen wir? Momentan
ist die Banane ...- Sicher?
... das grössere Highlight.
- Hey, Oskar.
Hoi. Hoi.
Hey.
- Aw.
Du kannst seine Nase streicheln.
Kein Problem.
- Er sabbert ein bisschen.
Ja, ja.
- (Kind) Aber das ist lustig.
(Ola) In Schweden
gibt es 300'000 freilebende Elche.
Aber man sieht sie nur selten.
Ja.
Ein netter Hut.
- Thank you.
Gut gegen Mücken.
- Yes.
Ola hat noch ein Dutzend mehr Elche
auf seiner Farm.
Sie sind sein Hobby
seit der Pensionierung.
Ola ist Sami.
Er hatte sein Leben lang
Rentierherden,
die er jetzt
an seine Kinder weitergegeben hat.
Heute Nacht werde ihre Rentierherde
markiert, sagt mir Ola.
Ich solle doch vorbeischauen.
Die Einladung nehme ich an:
Es ist eine Ehre,
bei diesem wichtigen Moment
im Leben einer Sami-Familie
dabei sein zu können.
* Sanfte Musik *
Mäx' Baby ist ein Bauprojekt.
Und zwar drüben,
auf der finnischen Seite des Flusses.
Wir fahren den Aavasaksa rauf,
den höchsten Hügel in der Gegend.
Gehört das alles euch?
Auf beiden Seiten?
Alles, ja.
- Du bist Grossgrundbesitzerin.
Ja.
- Schon, oder?
Wie viel Fläche ist das?
- Wie viel ist es?- 120'000 m2.
Yasmine und Mäx
wollen hier Blockhäuser hinstellen.
Wo wollt ihr bauen?
- Hier überall.
Überall?
- Das gehört alles uns.
Das waren vorher alles Bäume.
Die Strasse ist erschlossen,
Wasser ist da,
Abwasser, Strom, Glasfaser ...
20 Blockhäuser sind geplant,
in verschiedenen Grössen.
Es sind Fertighäuser,
bereit in vier Wochen.
Baustart: so bald wie möglich.
Mir wird fast schwindlig,
so gross sind Mäx' Pläne.
Was hast du für all das bezahlt?
Gute Frage.
Wir haben noch gar nicht bezahlt.
Wir haben mal unterschrieben.
Wir müssen zahlen,
wenn wir das Baugesuch eingeben.
Der Prozess ...
Es ist an uns überschrieben.
Wenn wir das Baugesuch eingeben,
müssen wir bezahlen.
Wenn wir zu lange warten,
fällt es zurück an die Gemeinde.
Wir müssen das
in den nächsten drei Jahren bebauen.
Das ist ein riesiges Projekt.
Gibt es Momente, in denen du sagst:
"Einfach mal ..."
Ja, ja.
- Sicher?- Ja, ja.
In denen ich die Handbremse ziehe?
Ja.
Musst du das manchmal?
- Ja.
Er hatte schon Ideen ...
... wo ich fand: "Ganz ruhig."
"Einen Gang runterschalten."
- Ohne Yasi wäre ich abgehoben.
Ich brauche sie an meiner Seite,
damit sie reflektiert.
All meine Ideen und Sachen,
die ich zusammenspinne ...
Dann stellt sie drei Fragen
und ich sage, "Okay, du hast recht",
und gehe wieder arbeiten.
Viele suchen die Ruhe
hier oben im hohen Norden.
Henslers das Gegenteil.
So viele Geschäftsideen
und Herausforderungen:
Schafft man das, ohne dass
das Familienglück darunter leidet?
Die letzten fünf Jahre
haben wir als Familie viel gemacht.
Aber
wir kamen manchmal doch zu kurz.
Man fokussiert sich halt
aufs Geschäft, die Gäste kommen ...
Man muss dort sein
und man ist auch dort.
Ich möchte wieder mehr Zeit haben.
- Ja.
Wieder mal Ferien zusammen machen.
- Genau.
Könnt ihr das noch?
- Nein.
Wisst ihr noch, wie das geht?
- Ich glaube schon.
Aber wir haben das hintenangestellt.
Wir diskutieren
immer wieder darüber.
Wir haben gesagt, dass wir dieses
Jahr Familienferien versuchen.
Wir sind an einem Punkt, an dem
es in die andere Richtung geht.
Wir wollen als Familie mehr Zeit.
Wo wird der Familienmittelpunkt
in Zukunft sein?
In der Schweiz
oder hier im hohen Norden?
Für mich und die Kinder
ist der Mittelpunkt die Schweiz.
Sie gehen dort zur Schule,
wir haben eine Wohnung ...
Aber für sie
ist es hier auch ein Heimkommen.
Kimi war mehr hier oben
als in der Schweiz.
Sie geniessen beides.
Wir versuchen,
das unter einen Hut zu bringen.
Wir üben auch.
Wir machen das erst ein paar Monate.
So weit geht es gut.
- Ja.
Ich glaube, wir schaffen das.
Wir haben schon anderes geschafft.
Auf jeden Fall.
* Sanfte Musik *
Schon fast Mitternacht.
Die Stimmung ist unbeschreiblich.
Es ist viel zu schön,
um schlafen zu gehen.
In dieser hellen Nacht
findet die Rentiermarkierung statt,
zu der mich
Elchbesitzer Ola eingeladen hat.
Heute ist der erste Tag
der Markierung der Kälber.
Die Rentiere wurden übrigens nicht
mit dem Helikopter zusammengetrieben,
sagt man mir,
sondern mit Hunden und Quads.
Rentiere bewegen sich zwar frei,
aber sie gehören trotzdem jemandem.
Die Tiere sind vom Clan von Ola Rokka
und
anderen Sami-Familien aus der Gegend.
Das hier
ist nur ein kleiner Teil der Herde.
Wir haben 2'200 km2 Land, das wir
für die Rentiere nutzen dürfen.
Der Staat stellt uns
dieses Land zur Verfügung,
weil wir als Samen
traditionell mit Rentieren arbeiten.
Man darf aber
nicht zu viele Rentiere halten.
Wir rechnen mit einem Rentier
pro Quadratkilometer.
Macht also 2'200 Rentiere.
Wenn du 4'000 Rentiere hast,
dann ist das sehr schlecht
für die Natur
und die nächste Generation.
Weil sie dann alles wegfressen
und nichts mehr
für den Winter übrig bleibt.
Der erste Schritt der Markierung ist,
herauszufinden,
welchem Besitzer die Kälber gehören.
Dafür erhalten die kleinen Rentiere
eine Nummer.
Die 14-jährige Madeleine Johansen
hilft, die Kleinen einzufangen.
Knapp zwei Monate alt sind sie.
Madeleine ist dafür extra
2 1/2 Std. angereist, erfahre ich.
Hast du deine Rentiere gefunden?
Ich habe keine eigenen Tiere.
Du hilfst einfach?
- Mein Onkel hat Rentiere.
Kannst du dir vorstellen,
später selber eigene Tiere zu haben?
Ja.
Ich habe vor,
einmal meine eigene Herde zu haben.
Aber das
wird noch eine Weile dauern.
Yeah?
Was für ein Messer ist das?
Dieses Messer benutzen wir
für die Markierung am Ohr.
Es ist klein und man hält es so,
mit dem Daumen.
Manchmal schneidet man sich selber
damit, weil es so scharf ist.
Es hat einen guten Griff.
A good grip. Yeah.
Trägst du
einen traditionellen Sami-Gurt?
Ja, jeder ist anders.
Das ist meiner.
Er ist hübsch.
- Yeah, it's very nice.
Aber auch ziemlich teuer.
Er kostet fast 100 Fr.
Ah, okay.
Die Kälber haben sich
in der Zwischenzeit wieder beruhigt
und sind zurück bei ihren Müttern.
Jetzt wird notiert,
welches Kalb wem gehört.
Dann
beginnt die eigentliche Markierung.
Jeder Clan
hat sein eigenes Kerbenmuster,
das man den Tieren ins Ohr schneidet.
Seit Hunderten von Jahren
wird das so gemacht.
Es tue den Tieren nicht mehr weh,
als wenn man uns einen Ohrring
stechen würde, sagen sie mir.
Ich hoffe, das stimmt.
Girl power.
* Mystische, erwartungsvolle Musik *
Um 4 Uhr morgens
werden die Tiere wieder freigelassen.
Damit sie sich nicht mit denen mi-
schen, die nächste Nacht drankommen,
schickt man sie über den Fluss.
Ein einzigartiges Bild.
Und eine eindrückliche Erfahrung.
* Mystische, erwartungsvolle Musik *
Und wieder unterwegs durch die Weite
von Schwedisch Lappland.
Das Gefühl für Zeit und Distanz
ist mir schon lange abhandengekommen.
Die nächsten 400 km,
von Övertornea nach Sorsele.
Dort, im schwedischen Innenland,
lebt auch eine Schweizerin:
Sabine Zimmermann.
Eigentlich kam die Bündnerin Sabine
nur nach Schweden,
um den Kopf durchzulüften:
Stress im Job
und auch noch eine Beziehung,
die zu Ende gegangen war.
Aber es kam etwas anders,
als sie es sich vorgestellt hatte.
Und wie,
erzählt sie uns gleich selbst.
Wir treffen sie gleich.
Sie hat mich an den Strand bestellt.
Bei diesem Wetter.
Nordic Lifestyle, sage ich nur.
Solange ich nicht baden muss,
bin ich dabei.
* Sanfte Musik *
Ich schaue kurz.
Sabine erwartet mich
mit Mann und Kindern am Flussufer.
Und das bei gefühlten 10 °C
und einem bissigen Wind.
Hoi, Sabine. Mona.
- Hoi.
Es freut mich sehr.
- Mich auch.
Gutes Strandwetter.
- Wir feiern den Sommerferienstart.
Darum sind wir hier.
- Das ist heute?
Ja. Die Kinder
haben schon seit Donnerstag frei,
aber ich habe seit heute Ferien.
Hättest du gedacht, dass du mal Teil
einer normalen schwedischen Familie
sein wirst?
Nein, das hätte ich nie gedacht.
Das war nicht mein Plan,
als ich nach Schweden kam.
Du wolltest hier
etwas Abstand gewinnen.
Ja.
- Warum bist du immer noch hier?
Deswegen.
Weil wir uns begegnet sind.
Zuerst waren wir einfach Kumpels.
Aber dann funkte es trotzdem.
- Ja.
Und ...
Ganz am Anfang ...
... überlegte man,
ob man in Schweden ...
Er wäre
auch in die Schweiz gekommen.
Aber als wir
eine Weile zusammen waren,
wurde immer klarer,
dass es Schweden ist.
Er findet, es habe
zu viele Menschen in der Schweiz.
Und sie seien zu nahe aufeinander.
- Ja.
Hast du deine Badesachen dabei?
Ja.
Ja, nein. Man kommt nur einmal
im Sommer nach Lappland.
Dann muss man es sich geben.
- Es sind ca. 12 °C. Geschätzt.
Nein, 14 °C.
- 14 °C?
Aber wir können uns am Feuer
ein bisschen vorwärmen.- Ja.
Heimlich spekuliere ich darauf,
dass die Badepläne
am Feuer vergessen gehen.
Der Grillmeister und Mann von Sabine
heisst Danne.
Mona, du kannst dort
ein Messer und eine Gabel nehmen.
Astrid, du auch.
Dort hinten
hat es sogar etwas Sonnenlicht.
Das erste von heute.
- Du bist eine Optimistin.
Oder, Sabine?
- Schon den ganzen Tag.- Very much.
"Very much." Really?
Is she an optimist?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Das ist wirklich ... Mitten im Orkan
machen wir ein Picknick.
Hm?
- Der Sommer ist so kurz hier ...
Je kürzer der Sommer,
desto länger der Winter.
Vor ein paar Monaten
sah der Fluss so aus.
Anstatt an den Strand,
begleiten wir Sabine zum Eisfischen.
Im Anhänger
die beiden Kinder Mattis und Astrid.
* Sie spricht schwedisch. *
Dort ist ein Elch.
Seht ihr ihn?
Das ist nicht mehr so besonders
wie vor zwölf Jahren.
Aber jedes Mal trotzdem schön,
wenn man einen sieht.
Um zu fischen, müssen zuerst Löcher
ins Eis gebohrt werden.
Dann pimpelt man.
Das
nennt sich "pimpla" auf Schwedisch.
Eisfischen.
Man geht ein bisschen auf und ab.
Sabine fing ihren letzten Fisch
vor zwei Jahren.
* Lustige, erwartungsvolle Musik *
Je länger nichts anbeisst,
desto grösser wird das,
was auf Dannes Kappe steht.
Es wäre schön, einen zu kriegen.
Ein leckeres Nachtessen.
* Lustige, erwartungsvolle Musik *
* Ausruf *
Wohoo!
Ja!
* Sie spricht schwedisch. *
Ich hatte Glück.
Das ist so ein schönes Gefühl.
Ich habe so darauf gewartet.
* Sie sprechen schwedisch. *
Ich bin froh, dass
überhaupt jemand etwas gefangen hat.
That was perfect.
* Lustige, erwartungsvolle Musik *
Es ist fast schwieriger,
ihn in der Pfanne zu braten,
als ihn am Haken rauszuziehen.
Mmh, das wird so lecker.
Guten Appetit.
* Sie spricht schwedisch. *
Das Schicksal scheint für jedes Le-
bewesen seinen eigenen Plan zu haben.
Und so hat es auch Sabine und Danne
zueinander geführt.
Beide
arbeiteten auf derselben Hundefarm.
Er überzeugter Single,
sie frisch aus einer Beziehung
und gar nicht auf der Suche
nach einem neuen Partner.
Sabine hatte ein anderes Problem:
Ihr Häuschen
war nämlich ohne Heizung.
Ich hatte Mitleid mit Sabine.
Weil sie in ihrem eiskalten Häuschen
sitzen musste.
Ohne Heizung.
Ich versuchte,
das Häuschen besser zu isolieren
und machte einen neuen Boden rein.
Damit es wenigstens über 0 °C war
da drinnen.
Aber es war immer noch
ein sehr, sehr kaltes Häuschen.
Wir redeten jeden Abend miteinander.
Wir sassen am Feuer,
redeten und hatten eine gute Zeit.
Du gabst mir Schweizer Schokolade.
Fast jeden Tag.
- Nein.
Doch. Du hast immer gesagt:
"Hier, nimm etwas Schokolade."
Jo, jo.
- Okay.
Irgendwann
wurde ich von einem Hund gebissen.
Ich musste nach Umea,
um mich operieren
bzw. nähen zu lassen.
Irgendwann kriegte ich eine SMS:
"Oh, so doof,
dass das passiert ist."
Und ein paar Stunden später kam:
"Ich vermisse dich ein wenig."
Kurz bevor ich aus Umea zurückkam,
mit meiner verletzten Hand,
schrieb Danne, es sei -38 °C,
ich könne nicht in meine Hütte.
Dann kam es eben so ...
Es sei auch okay, wenn ich zu ihm
in die Hütte schlafen kommen.
Er bot mir dann auch sein Bett an,
das unten war.
Und er kletterte
eine senkrechte Leiter hoch,
und dort oben hatte es zwei Betten.
Das wäre mit meiner Hand
nicht gegangen.
Auch dort ein Gentleman.
Dann lagen wir so im Dunkeln dort.
Dann sagte er
in die dunkle Hütte rein:
"Wir wären
eigentlich ein gutes Paar."
Und ich sagte: "Ja."
Aber mehr als das,
war an dem Abend nicht.
Aber dann wussten wir, dass sich das
vielleicht noch zu etwas entwickelt.
Und so kam es ja auch.
Die beiden verliebten sich
und gründeten eine Familie.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
* Sie sprechen schwedisch. *
Wir haben genug Zeit,
also daher keinen Stress.
Aber weil wir alle so langsam sind -
bzw. v.a. die Kinder -,
wird es am Schluss stressig.
Zusammen mit den Kindern macht Sabine
sich auf den Weg nach Sorsele.
Astrid und Mattis
gehen dort zur Schule.
Sabine arbeitet als Primarlehrerin.
Ich finde es einfach schön.
Wir sind mitten in der Natur.
Es hat kein anderes Auto.
Doch, jetzt kommt eins.
Schau. Unglaublich.
Und ...
Das ist wie eine gute Einstimmung,
um zur Arbeit zu gehen.
Finde ich.
Es sind 20 Min. Fahrt
bis nach Sorsele.
Das Dorf hat nur
1'000 Einwohnerinnen und Einwohner.
Das reicht aber,
um das Zentrum der Region zu sein.
Hej, Rebecca.
* Gutenmorgenlied auf Schwedisch *
Um als Lehrerin arbeiten zu können,
musste Sabine Schwedisch
auf Hochschulniveau studieren.
Sabine, kommst du mal?
Die Kinder rufen Lehrerin Sabine
bei ihrem Vornamen.
* Sie sprechen schwedisch. *
Sogar die Politiker duzen sich.
Den König kann man auch duzen.
Das ist so normal hier.
Eine unkomplizierte Mentalität.
Ich habe mich so daran gewöhnt, dass
es für mich in der Schweiz fast ...
... eine Anstrengung ist,
zum Siezen zurückzufinden.
Es gelingt mir nicht mehr immer.
Der schulische Druck sei in Schweden
kleiner als in der Schweiz,
sagt Sabine.
Manchmal wünscht sie sich sogar,
es wäre
etwas weniger locker an ihrer Schule.
Sabine kommt häufig
später nach Hause als Danne.
Hallo.
Danne arbeitet
als selbstständiger Schreiner.
Wer zuerst zu Hause ist, kocht.
Fleisch und Kartoffeln.
Das ist es in etwa.
Es ist ein Paket aus der Schweiz
angekommen.
Ein Highlight für die Kinder,
aber auch für Sabine.
Sie vermisst viele Produkte
aus der alten Heimat.
Aber noch mehr
ihre Freunde und Verwandten.
Das ist die Jacke.
Die ist von Grossmami.
Man möchte so gerne ...
... einfach
spontan beieinander vorbei.
Das geht einfach nicht.
Es ist immer alles
in der digitalen Welt.
Man hat so
schon das Gefühl von Nähe ...
Hoffentlich gehen wir
im Sommer in die Schweiz.
Es wird komisch sein,
einander wirklich zu sehen.
Und sich
in die Arme nehmen zu können.
Ist sie zu klein? Ist sie?
Du bist einfach mega gewachsen
in letzter Zeit.
Jetzt rufe ich Grossmami an.
Hallo.
Gotti hat mir gesagt,
ihr hättet das Paket gekriegt.
Ja, danke.
Ja. Habt ihr es schon geöffnet?
- Ja. Also ...
Die Jacke war megagut,
aber ein bisschen zu klein.
Schon zu klein? Du musst
wieder etwas kleiner werden.
Ja.
* Sanfte Musik *
Es ist ein Leben
an einem abgeschiedenen Ort.
Ein Leben nahe an der Natur.
Die Familie
ist viel draussen unterwegs.
Heute gibt es eine Wanderung.
Ist das extra Sandwichbrot?
Polarkaka.
Ja. Ja ...
"Koka".
- Ah, "Koka".
"Polarkoka". "Koka".
* Verspielte Musik *
So.
Haben wir alles?
- Ja.- Ja.
Ja.
Wir fahren Richtung Hochfjell.
Das schwedische Hochland mit Bergen
bis über die Baumgrenze.
Sabine und ihre Familie
machen hier jedes Jahr
mehrtägige Wanderungen
mit Zelt und Schlafsack.
Heute gibt es nur eine kleine Runde.
Die macht man als schwedisches Kind
locker in den Gummistiefeln.
Dass
die wilde Schönheit des Hochfjells
Sabine und Danne so begeistert,
verstehe ich gut.
Oh, das ist schön.
Ihr habt euch kennengelernt, weil es
euch beide in dieses Hochfjell zog?
Ja.
Eigentlich ist es ein bisschen so.
Wir sind beide hier oben gelandet,
weil wir die Landschaft hier oben
so gerne mögen.
Hier komme ich
den Bündner Bergen am nächsten.
Für dich ist das ein bisschen -
kein Ersatz, aber eine Annäherung.
Ja.
Hier heimelt es mir.
Heimat ist für dich
inzwischen Schweden, oder?
Oder immer noch die Schweiz?
Ich bin
wirklich zu Hause in Schweden.
Aber wenn ich nur schon die
Buchstaben des Wortes "Chur" sehe,
wird es mir
immer noch warm ums Herz.
Das wird immer meine Heimat sein.
You have the love for this landscape
in common.
But there are also differences
between the both of you.
Wir sind
eigentlich sehr verschieden.
Ja?
- Das ist schon ...
Du sprichst etwas mehr als Danne.
Stimmt das?
- Ich habe das nicht verstanden.
Spreche ich mehr als du?
Oh ja, definitiv.
Definitely.
- Definitely.
Jo, jo.
- Ja.
Ich denke, ich bin ein ruhiger Typ.
Deshalb ist es auch nicht schwer
für Sabine, mehr zu reden als ich.
Da muss man nicht viel reden.
Aber darüber
denke ich nicht gross nach.
Ist das dieses Schwedische?
Wie heisst das? Lagom.
Lagom.
- Ja.
Das ist sehr schwedisch.
Was bedeutet es genau?
Es bedeutet einfach:
nicht zu viel und nicht zu wenig.
Etwas so locker dazwischen.
Ja.
Das ist etwas sehr Zentrales
für uns Schweden.
Ja.
- Lagom.
Lagom.
Wir sind
sehr ruhig und zurückhaltend.
Wir schreien niemanden an.
Wir hupen nicht.
Wir versuchen es easy zu nehmen.
Wenn jemand solche Sachen macht,
finden wir Schweden:
"Das ist ein wenig too much."
Also warst du froh,
dass Sabine ruhige schwedische Männer
wie dich mag.
Ja, ich denke schon.
Sowas in der Art.
Jo, jo.
Die entspannte Ruhe widerspiegelt
sich in der Landschaft,
die ihre Schönheit aus dem Kargen,
aus dem Einfachen zieht.
Ich wäre gerne noch länger bei Sabine
und ihrer Familie geblieben,
aber auf mich
warten noch höhere Berge.
Und v.a. das Meer.
Meine Reise
geht weiter in Richtung Norwegen.
* Ruhige Klaviermusik *
Zwischen Schweden und Norwegen
liegend die Skanden,
das skandinavische Gebirge.
Es ist länger als die Alpen,
aber nur ca. 2'500 m hoch.
Mein Ziel sind die Lofoten,
eine Inselgruppe
vor der norwegischen Küste.
9 Std. Weg
mit dem Auto und der Fähre.
* Ruhige Klaviermusik *
* Sie pfeift vor sich hin. *
"Polcirkelns Gränshandel".
Das ist ein altes,
skandinavisches Sprichwort:
Man muss den Kaffee trinken,
wenn er da ist.
Du weisst nie,
wie viele Tausend Kilometer
zwischen dir und deiner
nächsten Kaffeepause liegen. Yes.
Oh, aha.
Hoi. Ich kriege einen Freund.
Ah, eine Freundin.
Hoi. Magst du Schokolade?
Schweizer Nöt?
Hm? Schau, was man hier findet.
Schweizer Nüsse hat es hier drin.
Aber schwedische Schokolade.
Magst du das?
Das solltest du nicht essen.
* Entspannte Musik *
Die Grenze zu Norwegen
liegt gerade auf der Passhöhe.
Von jetzt an geht es nur noch runter.
Bis ans Meer.
* Entspannte Musik *
Je weiter wir
auf dem Meer draussen sind,
desto stürmischer wird es.
Hey.
Hey. Hey.
Nein, wir müssen rein.
Nein. Es geht nicht mehr.
* Verspielte, folkloristische Musik *
Mein Ziel ist Henningsvaer,
ein kleines Fischerdorf
auf der Insel.
Nach der Fähre
muss ich mit dem Auto weiter.
Das Wetter wechselt schnell
hier am nordischen Meer.
Berge, die steil ins Wasser fallen -
welch ein Anblick.
* Verspielte, folkloristische Musik *
Kein Wunder, zieht es im Sommer
viele Touristen auf die Lofoten -
häufig mit dem Camper.
Wie ganz viele andere,
fuhr auch Lorenzo von Holzen mit
seinem Bus hinauf nach Henningsvaer.
Aber er ging danach
einfach nicht mehr zurück.
Der junge Nidwaldner baute sich
in kurzer Zeit eine Schreinerei auf,
fand seinen Liebe und heiratet sie
auch gleich. Und zwar heute.
Das ist es: Henningsvaer.
* Sanfte, verträumte Musik *
Nur 500 Menschen
wohnen das ganze Jahr durch hier.
Einer davon kommt aus Nidwalden.
Lorenzo von Holzen
wohnt in diesem Häuschen,
zusammen
mit seiner Schon-fast-Ehefrau Nelly.
Hej, hej.
- Salü.
Hoi. Hoi.
- Oh.
Hallo.
- Lorenzo. Mona.
Salü. Freut mich. Komm rein.
- Freut mich sehr.
Wenn jemand Schweizerdeutsch spricht,
bin ich richtig.
Hi. Mona. Schön, dich kennenzulernen.
- Hi. Nelly.
An diesem speziellen Tag.
Ja, ein sehr spezieller Tag.
Wie fühlst du dich?
Du heiratest heute.
Wir haben eben darüber gesprochen.
Es ist ein spezieller Tag, aber
irgendwie auch ein normaler Tag.
Es fühlt sich natürlich an.
Selbstverständlich
werde ich ihn heute heiraten.
Of course.
- It's very nice.
Ja. Wie habt ihr euch kennengelernt?
Am Anfang hattet ihr total
unterschiedliche Wohnsituationen.
Wo wohntest du?
Ich kam im August vor zwei Jahren
hierher und schaute einfach mal,
wie es so ist hier.
Ich lebte dann
immer im Van oder im Auto.
Eigentlich bis im ...
Bis ich hier eingezogen bin,
lebte ich im Van.
Auch im Winter. Das war
nicht immer angenehm, aber ging gut.
Er lebte im Bus.
Was dachtest du dir, als er sagte:
"Ich komme aus der Schweiz
und lebe im Bus."
Hier oben zählt mehr,
was für eine Person du bist.
Und weniger, was du machst, wie viel
Geld du hast oder welche Ausbildung.
Ich dachte mir nicht viel dabei.
Ich fand ihn einfach sehr hübsch.
Es war alles sehr einfach.
Wir haben beide einen Hund,
wir gehen gerne wandern,
wir hatten gute Gespräche ...
Nach vier Treffen
bin ich hier eingezogen.
Ja, schon nach einer Woche.
Und er ist nicht mehr ausgezogen.
Seit zwei Jahren leben sie zusammen.
Mit den Hunden Kiülling und Vilja
und den Bewohnerinnen
dieses prächtigen Hühnerstalls.
Selbst gezimmert natürlich.
Hereinspaziert.
Nelly -
aufgewachsen im Süden von Norwegen -
sah das Häuschen per Zufall im
Internet und verliebte sich direkt.
Sie arbeitet als Lehrerin
in Henningsvaer.
(Flüsternd) It's a bit off.
Da sieht man einen Sneak Peek.
Dürfen wir dein Hochzeitskleid sehen?
Ah, ja, ja. Lorenzo
hat mich schon im Kleid gesehen.
Der Schleier ist etwas Besonderes.
Die Haarspange
habe ich von meiner Grossmutter.
Sie starb vor zwei Jahren.
Und der Schleier selber
ist eigentlich einfach ein altes
Tischtuch aus dem Brockenhaus.
Was ist das?
- Die Nidwaldner Sonntagstracht.
Die hast du?
- Sie gehört meiner Grossmutter.
Aber ich durfte sie ausleihen.
Meistens braucht man die
an der Älplerchilbi in Stans.
Ja.
Ich habe ein Geschenk mitgebracht.
My wedding present for you.
It's something very Swiss but ...
Oh, it's cheese. Yes.
It's Swiss cheese.
- Sbrinz.
Oh, it's Sbrinz. Yay.
Oh, now you're happy.
Danke vielmals.
- Thank you.
Ich habe gerade
meinen letzten Gruyère gegessen.
Ich habe gehört, Käse sei wichtig.
Zumindest für ihn.
Sehr wichtig.
- Erzähl.
Ich mag Käse auch.
Für Lorenzo ist er aber wichtiger.
Es ist etwas Spezielles
mit dem Schweizer Käse.
Können wir das schnell zeigen?
Das habe ich noch nie gesehen.
Ein Stück Käse
auf den Fuss tätowiert.
Es könnte auch hier sein.
- Auf dem Herz.
Aber hier
hat es eine Doppelbedeutung.
Ja ...
Der norwegische Käse sei leider ziem-
lich ungeniessbar, findet Lorenzo.
Dann
kommen schon die beiden Trauzeugen.
Hej.
* Sie begrüssen sich. *
Wohoo.
* Sie sprechen norwegisch. *
Das ist
so ein wohliger Moment gerade.
Meine besten Freundinnen,
die mir die Haare machen.
That's just nice.
That is good. We want it right here.
* Sie sprechen norwegisch. *
Oh, it's perfect, Nelly.
Wow. Passt schon.
* Er spielt eine kurze Melodie. *
* Verträumte Musik *
Musst du den Hut abnehmen?
- Das ist kein heiliger Ort, oder?
Nein, das sind keine heiligen Räume.
Seid ihr bereit?
- Ja.
Liebes Brautpaar,
liebe Nelly, lieber Lorenzo.
Ihr seid hierhergekommen,
um zu heiraten.
Ich möchte euch die Bedeutsamkeit
in Erinnerung rufen,
wenn zwei Menschen sich dazu
entscheiden, in Ehe zu leben.
Durch die Heirat
werdet ihr eine Einheit.
Dennoch bleibt ihr
zwei unabhängige Menschen.
Es gibt keinen Widerspruch
zwischen Liebe und Freiheit.
Liebe bedeutet auch,
Respekt für den anderen zu haben.
Nelly Maria Bye:
Möchtest du Lorenzo von Holzen -
der an deiner Seite steht -
zu deinem Mann nehmen?
- Ja.
Dann frage ich dich,
Lorenzo von Holzen:
Möchtest du Nelly Maria Bye -
die an deiner Seite steht -
zu deiner Frau nehmen?
- Ja.
Da ihr im Beisein von Zeugen
euch versprochen habt,
zusammen in der Ehe zu leben,
erkläre ich euch zu Mann und Frau.
Juhu.
- Gratuliere.
* Verträumte Musik *
Hey, congratulations.
Thank you.
- Alles, alles Liebe.
All the best for you.
Ich gratuliere ganz herzlich.
* Sie sprechen norwegisch. *
Es ist
ein kleines Fest unter Freunden.
Die grosse Hochzeit
mit allen Verwandten
ist dann
in einem Jahr in der Schweiz.
* Verträumte, erwartungsvolle Musik *
Am nächsten Morgen
schlafen Nelly und Lorenzo aus.
Und ich erkunde Henningsvaer.
Neben dem pittoresken Hafen
gibt es noch ein anderes Highlight:
den schönsten Fussballplatz der Welt.
Seine Schönheit zeigt sich aber
erst aus der Luft so richtig.
Da kickt man den Ball nicht auf
die Tribüne, sondern direkt ins Meer.
Jetzt treffen wir eine, die
wegen der Arbeit nach Norwegen kam.
Und zwar einfach darum,
weil es den Job, den sie macht,
in der Schweiz nicht gibt.
Irgendwo weit da draussen im Meer
arbeitet Andrea Eugster
auf einer Ölplattform.
Hätten wir dort filmen wollen,
hätten wir einen fünftägigen
Sicherheitskurs absolvieren müssen.
Darum gibt sie uns in einem Video-
tagebuch Einblick in ihre Arbeit.
Der Arbeitsplatz von Andrea Eugster
liegt 120 km
ab von der norwegischen Küste.
Der Name der Ölplattform: Gullfaks B.
Hier arbeitet Andrea
jetzt zwei Wochen am Stück.
Ihr Zimmer ist in diesem Block.
Jetzt geht es in meine Luxussuite.
Wir können sie uns anschauen.
Das ist unser Wohnquartier.
Es sieht überall gleich aus.
Der einzige Vorteil ist,
dass man immer dieselbe Kajüte hat.
Bzw. Luxussuite.
Ein kleines Zimmerchen.
Das funktioniert tipptopp.
Das Badezimmer. Frisch geputzt.
Und eine Dusche.
Aber:
Alle haben Meeresblick.
Hej, hej.
- Hallo.
Hej. Alles gut?
Hej, hej.
- Hej.
Es ist extrem spannend.
Es ist fast ein soziales Experiment.
Man fliegt
für 14 Tage auf diese Bohrinsel.
Und zwar mit dem Durchschnitt
der norwegischen Bevölkerung.
Da kommen 160 Leuten
kreuz und quer zusammen.
Man ist auf dieser menschen-
gemachten Insel mitten im Meer.
Als Instandhaltungsleiterin
ist Andrea Chefin
eines zwölfköpfigen Teams
aus Mechanikern,
Elektrikern und Automatikern.
Das ist die Büroecke.
Es wurde schon alles vorbereitet.
Der Name ist an der Türe.
Das Nächstwichtigste,
das wir brauchen: der Pager.
Jetzt ist wieder 24/7 Dienst.
Wenn etwas ist,
wird man Tag und Nacht abgerufen.
Das Allerwichtigste auf der
Plattform ist, sicher zu arbeiten.
Das macht man nicht im Büro.
Der Gasmesser ist natürlich wichtig.
Gas
in Kombination mit einer Zündquelle
kann zu einer Explosion führen.
Das ist extrem gefährlich.
* Sie spricht norwegisch. *
Die 36-Jährige ist nicht nur
für ihr eigenes Team verantwortlich,
sondern auch für externe Handwerker,
die für Auftragsarbeiten
auf die Plattform kommen.
* Sie sprechen norwegisch. *
Hier werden gerade die Betonsäulen
kontrolliert und ausgebessert.
Das Meer
ist an dieser Stelle 142 m tief.
Gullfaks
ist nur eines von rund 70 Ölfeldern,
die in der norwegischen Nordsee
betrieben werden.
Die Produktion von Erdöl und Erdgas
ist für Norwegen
von enormer Bedeutung
und hat das Land reich gemacht.
Die Firma Equinor - die vor
ein paar Jahre noch Statoil hiess -
ist mit knapp 20'000 Mitarbeitenden
der grösste Arbeitgeber in Norwegen.
Sie gehört zu zwei Drittel
dem norwegischen Staat.
Dank des Geldes
aus der Öl- und Gasindustrie
ist der norwegische Staatsfond
der grösste der Welt.
Gullfaks ist das erste,
rein norwegisch erschlossene Ölfeld
und seit den 80er-Jahren in Betrieb.
Neben Gullfaks B gibt es noch
die beiden Schwesternplattformen
Gullfaks A und C.
Um ans Öl zu kommen,
wird bis zu 3'000 m weit gebohrt,
in die Tiefe
und quer durch den Boden.
Die meisten
glauben Hollywood-bedingt,
dass man auf einer Plattform ist
und das Erdöl raufspritzt.
Das sieht richtig nach Action aus.
Wir sehen ...
Von den 160 Leuten,
die zu jeder Zeit an Bord sind,
sehen die wenigsten ...
Ich glaube, nur der Laborant
sieht zwischendurch mal Erdöl.
Andrea Eugster hat Geografie mit
Schwerpunkt Meteorologie studiert.
Für ihr Masterstudium
zog sie 2009 nach Norwegen.
Nach ihrem Abschluss kam sie
über das Thema Windkraft zu Equinor.
Knapp zehn Jahre später
hat sie innerhalb des Unternehmens
zur fossilen Energie gewechselt.
Die Idealistin Andrea hätte 2012,
als ich bei Equinor anfing, gesagt,
sie wolle nie mit Erdöl arbeiten.
Aber man sieht ...
Erdöl und Erdgas sind
für die moderne Gesellschaft ...
Wir haben alles darauf aufgebaut.
Wenn es so einfach wäre,
das zu ersetzen ...
... hätten wir das
schon lange gemacht.
Die Reaktion, wenn man sagt, man
arbeite auf einer Erdölplattform ...
Die Leute sind positiver
dazu eingestellt ...
Auch in dem Sinne ...
Wenn man sich die ganze Situation
mit dem Ukrainekrieg ...
... und der Gas-Supply von Russland
ansieht,
hat sich der Wind plötzlich gedreht.
Norwegen ist halt doch ein extrem
wichtiges Standbein für Europa.
Damit die sichere Lieferung
auch gewährleistet ist.
Frühstück, Mittagessen, Abendessen -
wir müssen essen.
Jetzt ist Abendessen
am Samstagabend. Kommt.
* Sie sprechen norwegisch. *
Was machst du
zwischen den Mahlzeiten?
Ich habe gerade
fünf Pullover gestrickt.
* Dynamische Musik *
Das Freizeitangebot auf der Bohrinsel
ist vielfältig.
* Sie sprechen norwegisch. *
* Applaus *
* Nachdenkliche Gitarrenmusik *
Hier sind ein paar meiner Kollegen
am Stricken.
Und das ist eine Schmuckwerkstatt.
Guten Tag, meine Damen und Herren.
Mein Name ist Kalle.
Wir haben viel Spass auf Gullfaks.
Tschüss.
Guten Morgen.
Ja ...
Wir sind in der Mitte der Tour.
Es ist kurz vor 6 Uhr
und Zeit zum Aufstehen.
Man merkt langsam ...
... dass es zu viele Nächte
mit zu wenig Schlaf sind.
4-5 Std.
Das ist ein bisschen wenig für mich
auf Dauer.
Aber was soll's.
Heute ist es da unten etwas wilder.
Für einen Sommertag jedenfalls.
Wir schauen mal draussen.
Ca. 5 m Wellenhöhe.
Signifikant im Moment.
Man sieht,
dass es da unten ziemlich tobt.
Aber im Vergleich zum Winter
ist das noch gar nichts.
Das kann sich unter der Plattform
so richtig aufbauen.
Dann schlägt es
auch mal richtig unten rein.
Es kann schon sein,
dass es dieses Gitter rausschlägt,
wenn es nicht mehr gut angemacht ist
und ein richtiger Brecher kommt.
Dann macht man als
Vorsichtsmassnahme hier unten zu.
Das sind die Rettungsboote.
Wir haben vier.
Wenn der Alarm losgeht ...
... treffen sich alle hier
und man geht in die Rettungsboote.
Es ist
nicht so gemütlich in den Booten.
Man ist wie in einer Sardinenbüchse.
Auch wenn man runterschaut ...
Das sind 30 m freier Fall.
Es gibt verschiedene Risiko...
...szenarien,
die wir immer wieder üben.
Was, wenn ein Helikopter anfliegt
und eine harte Landung hat?
Wie geht man mit Explosionen um?
Es kann auch sein, dass ein grosses
Schiff den Antrieb verliert
und auf die Plattform zudriftet.
Die ganze Plattformleitung
ist Teil des Bereitschaftsteams,
dem Emergency Response Team.
Wenn etwas ist, würden wir
in die Bereitschaftszentrale gehen
und von dort aus alles leiten.
Das wird regelmässig gedrillt.
Falls etwas passiert,
wissen so alle ...
Wenn etwas passiert, weiss niemand,
wie man wirklich reagiert.
Aber je mehr man trainiert,
umso besser kann man dann reagieren.
* Unverständliche Durchsage *
Attention, attention.
This is a drill. This is a drill.
All personnel ...
* Unverständlich *
... must go to the lifeboats.
* Unverständliche Durchsage *
Mit dem Einsteigen
ist diese Übung abgeschlossen.
Nur für Testzwecke wird das Boot
nicht ins Wasser gelassen.
Arbeitsfreie Tage
gibt es auf der Ölplattform keine.
Am Sonntag
gibt es immer einen Sonntagsputz.
Da sind alle dabei.
Alle haben ihre Module,
die sie putzen.
Und jetzt gibt es Waffeln für alle.
Und auch Würste.
Solche Gemeinschaftsaktionen tun
der Stimmung auf der Plattform gut
und sind eine
mehr als willkommene Abwechslung
nach zwei Wochen Arbeit am Stück
mit wenig Schlaf.
Den Inselkoller kriegt man auch.
Wie gesagt, man ist nicht immer
auf einem Hoch auf dieser Plattform.
V.a. wenn man gegen Ende Schicht
so richtig müde wird.
Dann kommt vielleicht jemand
mit einem dummen Kommentar oder so.
Dann denkt man: "Jetzt ist Zeit,
um nach Hause zu gehen."
Das Zuhause von Andrea
ist eine Helikopter-
plus eine Flugzeugstunde
von der Plattform entfernt.
In Royken, südlich von Oslo.
Hier wohnt Andrea
zusammen mit ihrem Freund,
dem Österreicher Günther Greck.
Wir trainieren nach Plan.
Wenn es sich arbeitstechnisch
einrichten lässt,
versuchen wir,
das zusammen zu machen.
Vor vier Jahren
funkte es zwischen den beiden,
und zwar am Iron Man in Südafrika.
Der Triathlonsport hat einen
wichtigen Platz in ihrer Beziehung.
Es ist ziemlich zeitintensiv.
Es gehen doch viele Stunden
mit dem Training drauf.
Wir trainieren jeden Tag,
oft auch zweimal pro Tag.
Wenn das nur einer macht
und der andere auf dem Sofa sitzt,
ginge das nicht.
- Das würde nicht funktionieren.
So kann man
die Zeit zusammen verbringen.
Auf dem Rad,
im Schwimmbad, beim Laufen ...
Es ist einfach schön.
* Entspannte Musik *
In ihren vier plattformfreien Wochen
macht Andrea nicht einfach nichts.
Sie arbeitet im Homeoffice
und studiert Management Leadership
im Fernstudium.
Sie und Günther
hatten lange eine Fernbeziehung.
An den letzten Weihnachten
zog Günther nach Norwegen.
Dafür musste er vieles aufgeben.
Die Sicherheit, die ich in Öster-
reich hatte mit meinem Job etc.
Wir waren zwei Jahre zusammen.
Aber es war dann doch ...
Im Endeffekt war die Entscheidung
relativ einfach.
Wenn das Gefühl stimmt, muss man ...
Einen Job bekommt man wieder.
Ich hatte das Gefühl,
wenn ich es nicht probiere,
könnte ich es hinterher bereuen.
So habe ich nichts zu bereuen.
Jetzt wird es spannend.
- I'm prepared.
Spannend.
- Das sieht lustig aus.
Nach der Auswanderung ging Günther
sogar noch einen Schritt weiter:
Er fragte Andrea,
ob sie ihn heiraten wolle.
Das Resultat: ein klares Ja.
Und ein Kurs für einen Hochzeitstanz.
* Sie spricht norwegisch. *
* Romantische Musik *
Ich habe nie von einer
Prinzessinnenhochzeit geträumt.
Als Günther fragte,
war die Antwort einfach.
Das war wie natürlich.
Wir waren am Wandern.
Fünf Tage in Jotunheimen.
Dann waren wir auf dem Gipfel ...
... und er fragte.
* Dramatische Tangomusik *
Links.
- Rechts. Andere ... Ja.
Ja, links für dich.
* Sie spricht norwegisch. *
Noch haben die beiden
ein paar Wochen Zeit,
bis zur Hochzeit
hoch über einem norwegischen Fjord.
Und ein paar Tage
nach dem Kurs für den Hochzeitstanz
hat Andrea
mir ein kurzes Video geschickt.
Wir sehen es uns an.
- Hoi, Mona.
Falls du bei unserer Hochzeit
noch im hohen Norden bist,
bist du herzlich eingeladen.
- Wir würden uns freuen.
Tschüss.
- Tschüss.
Völlig klar: So eine Einladung
lasse ich mir nicht entgehen.
Ich komme gerne.
Ich stelle fest: Im hohen Norden
wird wie wild geheiratet.
So kurz wie der Sommer
ist halt auch die Hochzeitssaison.
Ich bin immer noch im schönen
Henningsvaer auf den Lofoten.
Im Sommer ist der verschlafene Ort
ein beliebtes Ziel für Tagesausflüge.
Ursprünglich
ist Henningsvaer ein Fischerdorf.
Aber der Wirtschaftszweig
geht immer mehr zurück.
Von den Einheimischen sind viele
Junge in die Städte abgewandert.
Umgekehrt ziehen aber neue Leute
von ausserhalb hier hin.
Sie haben diese alte Fabrik zu
einem Kulturzentrum umfunktioniert.
Ohne die sog. Trevarefabrikken
wären Nelly und Lorenzo nicht
in Henningsvaer hängen geblieben.
Trevare heisst Holzwaren.
Die wurden hier hergestellt.
Aber auch Lebertran
wurde hier gemacht.
... knowing that there is nowhere
else to be than right here.
Nelly
fühlte sich dank der Trevarefabrikken
sofort wohl in Henningsvaer.
Und als Lorenzo frisch ins Dorf kam,
parkierte er seinen Bus
einfach mal für ein paar Wochen hier.
Wo hast du deinen Bus hingestellt?
Als keine Saison war,
hatte ich ihn ...
... hier vorne draussen.
- Da vorne?
Ja.
Im November
hatte ich ihn dann oft hier,
weil es so windig war
und es mir die Wellen sonst direkt
in den Bus reingeschlagen hätte.
Du fuhrst mit deinem Bus hierher
und hast hier gewohnt.
Aber du hattest anfangs ja nichts.
Auch keinen Job.
- Nein.
Ich bin einfach reingegangen
und fragte, ob sie Arbeit haben.
Es sah so aus, als würden sie bauen.
Das war so und ich konnte mithelfen.
Ich möchte sehen,
was Lorenzo alles geschreinert hat.
Are you coming with us
to look at the furniture?
Auf dem Weg nehmen wir Mats mit,
einen der vier Initianten
der Trevarefabrikken.
Die Bottiche brauchten sie früher,
um Lebertran zu machen.
This is a very nice room.
Nachdem sie
den Fisch gefangen hatten,
versuchten sie so viel wie möglich
davon zu verwenden.
Auch die Leber. Sie kochten sie
in den Bottichen aus.
Man solle in jedem Monat
mit einem "R" drin,
Lebertran nehme,
um gesund zu bleiben.
Ja.
Was hast du jetzt alles gemacht hier?
Zeig uns das schnell.
Hier eigentlich alle Möbel.
Die Tische und die Bänke.
Und die runden Tische dort.
Wow. Das ist wirklich megacool.
Erinnerst du dich daran,
wie Lorenzo hier aufkreuzte?
Ja.
Ich sah ein Auto kommen
und ein Hund sprang heraus.
"Wer ist denn das?"
Dann fragte Lorenzo, ob wir Arbeit
für einen Schreiner hätten.
Und wir sagten: "Ja, tatsächlich
haben wir einen Job für dich."
Er kam zum richtigen Zeitpunkt.
Lorenzo
überzeugte mit seinem Handwerk.
Endlich mal eine Lösung dafür,
wenn es draussen immer hell ist.
Oder?
Er hat auch
die Hotelzimmer ausgestattet.
Am Anfang musste er alles
mit Handwerkzeug machen.
Heute hat er eine eigene Schreinerei
und bildet sogar einen Lehrling aus.
Schweizer Handwerk
ist hier oben gefragt.
In einem Punkt
könnten die Norweger aber -
wenn es nach Lorenzo ginge - noch
Nachhilfe aus der Schweiz brauchen:
beim Käse.
Meine Gastgeber
zeigen mir auf dem Wochenmarkt,
was die Norweger darunter verstehen.
Sie nennen das Brunost - Braunkäse.
Wow, yes. Thank you.
Ich kann dir den Sack abnehmen.
- Ja. Also.
Es sieht speziell aus.
Es sieht wie Gummi aus.
Hey, das klebt mega.
Wuah.- Du musst einfach sagen,
es schmecke gut. "Mmh, so lecker."
Schwierig, das zu essen.
Als würde man in Kautschuk beissen.
Es gibt die sieben Todsünden
und Brunost.
Das ist nicht eine davon,
sondern die achte.- Ja.
Dass man das als Käse bezeichnet.
- Ja.
Ja, also ...
- Aber ...
Ich kann die Ehre von Brunost
nicht retten.
Das muss ich leider sagen.
Für jemanden, der ein Käsetattoo
auf dem Fuss hat ...
* Verträumte Musik *
Lorenzo und Nelly haben sich einen
traumhaften Ort zum Leben ausgesucht.
Wir hätten Henningsvaer aber auch
von seiner schönsten Seite erlebt,
sagen sie.
Es könne hier oben
sehr rau und stürmisch sein.
Für den Moment,
für die nächsten paar Jahre ...
... werden wir an diesem Ort sein.
- Ja.
Aber Nelly hat Lust,
ein bisschen ...
... die Schweiz kennenzulernen.
- Mhm.
Du denkst also daran, vielleicht
mal in der Schweiz zu leben?
Ich würde sehr gerne ein, zwei Jahre
in der Schweiz leben,
um die Sprache zu lernen.
Wenigstens so gut, dass ich besser
mit Lorenzos Mutter reden kann.
Das wäre grossartig.
Und ich liebe die Schweiz.
So schön, gutes Essen, nette Leute,
alles ist so hübsch,
und das Gras
ist perfekt geschnitten.
I love it.
Und eine eigene Familie?
Habt ihr Pläne oder Wünsche?
Ja.
Wir möchten Kinder und Familie.
Es wäre schön,
ein eigenes, kleines Rudel zu haben.
Was die Frischvermählten
da noch nicht wissen:
Nur ein paar Wochen später
ist Nelly schwanger.
Nächstes Jahr sind sie zu dritt.
Eigentlich wollte er die Schweiz
nur für drei Monate verlassen.
Ja, und jetzt sitzen wir hier.
Ich glaube,
das geht ganz vielen Menschen so.
Ich kenne da noch so eine Geschichte.
Derjenige, den wir jetzt treffen,
ist auch einfach weg aus der Schweiz,
weil er
seinen Jugendtraum umsetzten wollte:
Er wollte unbedingt Lastwagen fahren.
Und um richtig weite Strecken
fahren zu können, dachte er:
"Ich gehe nach Finnland."
Mittlerweile
ist er nicht mehr Lastwagenfahrer.
Lorenzo,
er ist wohl dein persönlicher Held.
Er macht nämlich Käse.
Und zwar richtigen Schweizer Käse
für Skandinavien.
Er wurde x-fach ausgezeichnet
als bester Käser.
Er heisst Peter Dörig,
kommt aus dem Thurgau,
und wir haben ihn
im Frühling besucht.
Ein gut gefüllter Käsekeller
mitten in Finnland:
Der ganze Stolz
des 53-jährigen Peter Dörig.
Mmh.
Saulecker.
Die Finnen sagten mir, ich solle
keinen zu rezenten Käse machen.
Die Finnen würden das nicht essen.
Sie seien es nicht gewohnt.
Ich dachte: "Einen mache ich.
Sonst esse ich ihn halt selbst."
Peter musste seinen Käse
nicht selber essen.
Im Gegenteil: Gerade der rezente Käse
kam bestens an bei den Finnen
und öffnete ihm Tür und Tor.
Peter hat das Käsen im Blut:
Er ist gebürtiger Appenzeller,
im Thurgau aufgewachsen,
und lernte
das Handwerk seines Vaters.
Wir hatten eine Käserei zu Hause.
Mein Vater
hatte eine Appenzeller Käserei.
Wir mussten
schon als kleine Kinder mithelfen.
Dann war auch klar ...
... dass ich
die Lehre als Käser mache.
Obwohl ich nach der Schule
Lastwagen fahren wollte.
Mein Vater meinte aber,
das sei kein Beruf,
ich müsse zuerst
etwas Richtiges lernen.
Ich könne
später noch Lastwagen fahren.
So lernte ich halt auch Käser.
Und erst nachher fuhr ich Lastwagen.
Heute arbeitet Peter
wieder in seinem Lehrberuf.
Seine Firma
ist eine Erfolgsgeschichte.
Für 4 Mio. Euro baute er eine Käserei
mit Restaurant und Shop.
Pro Jahr verarbeitet Peter
600'000 l Milch zu Käse.
Es ist ein Familienunternehmen,
das Peter
zusammen mit seiner Frau Jenni führt.
Moi.
- Moi.
Jenni hat ihren Beruf
als Ingenieurin für Traktormotore
für die Käserei aufgegeben.
Die beiden haben vier Kinder -
alles Mädchen.
Die älteste Tochter Ida
hilft auch mit im Betrieb.
Ich bin viel hier am Arbeiten.
In der Küche und am Servieren.
Sonst mache ich hier ...
... Instagram und so was
für die Käserei.
Eigentlich ist mein Traum,
das hier irgendwann zu übernehmen.
Und hier weiterzumachen,
wie Papa es bis jetzt macht.
Als Peter in Idas Alter war,
hatte er ganz andere Träume,
als den Betrieb seines Vaters
zu übernehmen.
Peter war schon immer ein Abenteurer,
der aus seinem kleinen Dorf
in die grosse Welt raus wollte.
Lastwagenfahrer waren seine Helden.
Die nordischen Länder
gefielen mir immer sehr gut.
Ich fuhr fast sechs Jahre lang ...
... zwischen
der Schweiz, Norwegen und Schweden.
Dann habe ich ...
1994 las ich ...
... im Schweizer Routiersheft ...
... dass die Finnen ...
... mit den Lastwagen
bis nach Zentralasien fahren.
Ein Freund in der Schweiz
war ein Finne.
Da sagte ich: "Schau mal,
die Finnen, die glatten Kerle."
"Die fahren nach Zentralasien."
Und er sagte: "Willst du mitfahren?"
Das war die Möglichkeit für mich,
nach Finnland zu gehen ...
... und nach Zentralasien zu fahren.
Strecken über 10'000-15'000 km.
Da gab es noch
keinen anderen Schweizer.
Das war noch ein Pionierleben.
Die Zeiten sind vorbei.
Ein bisschen scheint Peter
seinen wilden Jahren auf den
Überlandstrassen nachzutrauern.
Heute sitzt Peter als
fürsorglicher Vater hinters Steuer,
um seine vier Töchter
irgendwo abzuholen oder hinzubringen.
Peter wurde in Sastamala in Finnland
sesshaft.
Er wohnt mitten im Wald.
In einem Haus,
das seine Frau Jenni entworfen hat
und das doch stark
an ein Schweizer Chalet erinnert.
* Entspannte Musik *
* Er spricht finnisch. *
Zu Hause ist Peter
ein bisschen der Hahn im Korb.
Mit fünf Frauen und Mädchen
um sich herum.
Käse.
Käse rausnehmen, damit er warm wird.
Das ist immer wichtig.
Seine vier Töchter
heissen Ida, Ella, Linda und Fanny.
Guten Appetit.
- (Alle) Guten Appetit.
Zu Peters Besitz
gehört auch ein kleiner Weiler
mit alten Holzhäusern drauf.
Es ist schon schön hier, oder?
Salotalo heisst der Ort.
Übersetzt: Haus im tiefen Wald.
Noch ein paar Würste auf den Ofen,
damit wir was zu essen haben.
Ganz der Finne, gehört für Peter
nach 26 Jahren im Land
die Sauna auch im Sommer dazu.
Megawarm.
Schön. Das tut gut.
In Finnland sagt man:
Die Leute in der Sauna,
ob in der Badehose oder nackt,
sind sich alle gleichgestellt,
weil keiner eine Uniform anhat.
Darum fällt man wichtige
Entscheidungen in der Sauna.
* Entspannte Musik *
Guten Appetit.
* Sie spricht finnisch. *
* Kreischen *
Nach der Sauna
direkt in den See springen:
das finnische Glück von Peter Dörig.
Aber:
Peters Leben wäre anders verlaufen,
wäre da
kein Schicksalsschlag gewesen -
vor 20 Jahren
auf einer Lastwagentour.
Als ich bei Peter ankomme,
zeigt er mir als Erstes
voller Stolz sein kleines Paradies:
Salotalo.
Wann hast du den Ort gefunden?
1999.
Im Herbst hörte ich davon,
dass er zum Verkauf stand.
Wir fuhren mit dem Auto hierher
und sahen uns um.
Alles war grau und überwachsen.
Dann sah ich das alte Haus da oben.
Und ich dachte: "Potz, das ist es."
Es ist aus dem Jahr 1808.
Das ist wie eine Alphütte.
Ich weiss auch nicht ...
Obwohl ich nie Freude an Altem
hatte, tat es mir das Haus an.
Das ist die Küche.
Bitte schön.
Ich fühle mich ein bisschen
wie im finnischen Ballenberg.
Ja.
Das ist auch typisch finnisch,
das Brot.
Peter bedeutet die heimelige Hütte
viel, das merke ich.
Vielleicht gerade darum,
weil sie so ein starker Kontrast zu
seinem Lastwagenleben von früher ist,
als er immer auf Achse war.
Warum du in Finnland geblieben bist,
ist auch ein bisschen tragisch.
Du kamst ja mit einem Freund,
um Lastwagen zu fahren.
Und dann verschwand er.
Ja, im Oktober 1997 verschwand Reto.
Er war in Kasachstan verschollen.
Wusste man nicht, was passiert ist?
- Keine Ahnung.
Der Lastwagen?
- Lastwagen und er waren weg.
Das ging über Wochen und Monate ...
Bis wir ihn nach Hause,
nach Maienfeld, bringen konnten,
vergingen Jahre.
Die Geschichte
von Peters Freund Reto
wurde vor 20 Jahren
in einem Dokumentarfilm aufgerollt.
Peter macht sich in dem Film
nochmals auf die Spur
seines verschwundenen Freundes.
Die beiden
machten die ganz grossen Touren
von Finnland aus in den wilden Osten.
Durch karges
und dünn besiedeltes Gebiet.
* Bedrohliche Musik *
Kein Pannendienst,
dafür aber auch kein Chef,
der einen mit dem Handy überwacht.
Jedes Mal, wenn wir
von irgendwo nach Hause kamen
und an einen neuen Ort gingen,
zeichneten wir hier ein,
wo wir durchgefahren waren.
Hier sah ich Reto zum letzten Mal.
Seine Fahrt ging so nach Hause.
Und meine ging weiter nach Aschgabat
bis zur Entladung.
Ich war hier auf
dem Kaukasusgebirge, als ich erfuhr,
dass Reto verschwunden war.
Reto und sein Lkw
sind wie vom Erdboden verschluckt.
Nach zwei Monaten
findet man den Lastwagen:
abgebrannt, aber ohne Anhänger.
"Gesucht wird Herr Reto Bantli, ver-
schollen seit dem 24. Oktober 1997."
Hier sind wir
auf dem TIR-Parking in Balgasch.
Hier wurde Reto
zum letzten Mal lebend gesehen.
Ein Jahr nach Retos Verschwinden
taucht auch der Anhänger auf.
Die Spur führt zu zwei Russen,
die sich gegenseitig beschuldigen,
Reto Bantli umgebracht zu haben.
Ein Raubmord, um den Anhänger
zu klauen und zu verkaufen.
Vieles bleibt unklar.
Einer der beiden Verhafteten
zeigt der Polizei schliesslich,
wo Retos Körper begraben liegt.
* Bedrohliche Musik *
Eine DNA-Probe
beseitigt die letzten Zweifel.
Nach vier Jahren Ungewissheit.
Zurück bleiben Erinnerungen an Reto
und Fotos von den gemeinsamen Reisen.
Das war auch Bantli.
- Sicher?
Mit dem Roten? War der Rote seiner?
- Ja.
Du kamst ja mit ihm hierher.
Das war euer gemeinsamer ...
- ... Traum.
Ja.
Fühltest du dich verantwortlich?
Du bist ja hiergeblieben
und hast ihn gesucht.- Klar.
Ich war erst hier, 1995.
Ich erzählte Bantli davon,
nachdem ich in den Sommerferien
hier gewesen war.
Dann war er Feuer und Flamme.
Er wolle das auch.
Er wolle das auch erleben.
Ja ...
"Ein verdammter Vogel",
so sagten die Bündner.
"Ist schon ein verdammter Vogel,
dieser Reto."
Er war ein erdensguter Mensch.
Aber er hat halt gelebt.
Und damals im Frühling 1996,
als wir uns dazu entschieden,
zu gehen,
waren wir in Muttenz in einem Pub.
Wir tranken den ganzen Abend
Bier zusammen.
Danach
gingen wir zum Lastwagenparkplatz,
um schlafen zu gehen.
Auf dem Weg dorthin
stoppte Reto plötzlich,
zündete sich eine Zigarette an,
hielt mich und sagte:
"Verdammt, hast du dir überlegt,
was du meinen Eltern sagst,
wenn ich nicht nach Hause komme?"
- Mhm.
Und ich sagte: "Spinnst du?"
"Du hast zu viel getrunken.
Spinnst du? Was?"
Dann kam dieser Moment wirklich,
als ich mir überlegen musste,
was ich seinen Eltern sagen soll.
Ja.
- Ja ...
Das ist schon heftig:
Wenn das nicht passiert wäre, wärst
du nicht so lange hiergeblieben.
Du hättest deine Frau nicht kennen-
gelernt, ihr hättet keine Töchter ...
Du hättest
dein Glück auch nicht gefunden.
Ja.
- Denkst du manchmal darüber nach?
Daran habe ich auch schon gedacht.
Ob das ...
Man sagt ja, an dem Tag,
an dem man auf die Welt kommt ...
... wird der letzte Tag gesetzt,
und alles, was dazwischen ist.
Ein Stück weit
kann man es selber beeinflussen
und ein Stück weit
ist es Glück oder Schicksal.
Bei Reto war es mehr Schicksal,
das sich für mich in Glück ...
... verwandelt hat.
Er wird in meiner ganzen Geschichte
ein grosser Teil bleiben.
Mhm.
- Ja.
Wenn du jung, frei und wild bist,
gibt es doch nichts Schöneres.
Findest du das immer noch?
- Würde ich sofort wieder machen.
Aber nach dem Verlust von Reto
sei es nicht mehr dasselbe gewesen
und Peter hörte auf,
Lastwagen zu fahren.
Er fing an zu käsen,
wie schon sein Vater.
Und er wurde selber Vater -
von vier Töchtern.
Es wäre mir im Traum
nie in den Sinn gekommen,
dass ich irgendwann mal mit fünf
Frauen unter einem Dach leben werde.
Der Hund ist auch ein Weibchen,
die Schafe auch.
Es ist sehr feministisch
um mich herum.
Willkomm.
- Danke vielmals.
Hej. Moi.
- Moi.
Hey, hello. I'm Mona.
Jenni.
- Nice to meet you.
Willkommen in Finnland.
- Danke vielmals.
Ich sage noch deinen Töchtern Hallo.
- Ja.
Ida, oder? Hoi. Mona.
Ich habe dich in dem Beitrag gesehen.
Und ich dachte: "Krass,
wie gut dein Schweizerdeutsch ist."
Woher sprichst du
so gut Schweizerdeutsch?
Von Cousins, Opa usw.
Die sind halt alle in der Schweiz.
Ich wollte es auch
von klein auf immer lernen.
Ich wollte immer
mit meiner Familie hier in Finnland
eine Sprache haben,
die niemand sonst versteht.
Z.B.
mit meinen Schwestern in der Schule:
Wir können einfach reden
und niemand versteht, was wir sagen.
Sprecht ihr jeweils Schweizerdeutsch
als Geheimsprache?
Und alle denken: "Was?"
Okay.
Sprichst du auch Schweizerdeutsch?
Ein bisschen.
- Ja, ja. Super.
Idas und Fannys Eltern
lernten sich auf dem Markt kennen.
Peter war sofort Feuer und Flamme.
Jenni aber hatte einen Freund.
Als ihr euch kennengelernt habt,
gab es ja durchaus Konkurrenz,
habe ich gehört.
Jenni? Es hat schon ...
Jetzt kommt es aus.
- Also ...
Ich habe gehört, du hättest
nicht auf den Schweizer gewartet,
es habe ein paar andere
oder mind. einen anderen gegeben.
Und dann?
Was hatte er, dass du fandest ...
Ich bin gespannt, was jetzt kommt.
* Sie spricht finnisch. *
Sie war sehr jung, als sie mit ...
... ihrem Freund zusammenkam.
Sie dachte immer, weil sie
schon so jung zusammen waren,
dass sie mal noch was anderes
im Leben machen müsse.
Sie war nicht sicher,
ob er der Richtige war.
Dann war sie mal
an der Tankstelle im Dorf.
Da dachte sie, wenn jetzt einer
mit einem Motorrad hinfahren würde,
würde sie hinten raufspringen
und mit ihm wegfahren.
Einen Monat später
kam ich mit einem Motorrad.
Das war wohl mein Vorteil:
das Motorrad.
Nein.
- Ohne Motorrad ...
Ja, ohne Motorrad wäre
vielleicht nichts daraus geworden.
Dann wärt ihr nicht hier.
Wir sind dankbar um das Motorrad.
Als Mädchen träumte sie
auch immer vom Lastwagenfahren.
Vom Beruf des Lastwagenfahrers.
Sie dachte immer,
das wäre auch etwas für sie.
Aber sie mochte Käse nicht.
- Nein.
Wirklich nicht?
- Ja.
Sicher? Du mochtest keinen Käse?
Und jetzt habt ihr
ein Käseimperium aufgebaut.
Sie musste üben,
um Käse zu essen.
Nein, das ist ja unglaublich.
Ein weiteres
skandinavisches Sprichwort sagt:
"Es gibt kein schlechtes Wetter,
nur zu kleine Flamingos."
Ich bin Teil eines speziellen Ri-
tuals, um die Badesaison zu eröffnen.
Mit einem alten Schilter-Traktor
aus Nidwalden
wird dieser riesige Flamingo
zum See gebracht.
Ich kann ihn gar nicht ...
* Lachen *
Ich komme nicht mehr hoch.
Jetzt lassen wir ihn etwas runter.
Auf welche Seite?
- Ja, dort hat er keinen Flügel.
Noch etwas mehr aufstellen.
Jetzt kommt dann der Kopf.
- Ja.
* Lustige Klänge *
* Ausrufe und Lachen *
Oh nein.
Erwischst du ihn?
Bravo.
Von allen Ländern, in denen ich war -
Finnland, Schweden und Norwegen -,
sind die Finnen die Speziellsten,
finde ich.
Die Kurligsten,
aber auf eine sehr gute Art.
Was denkst du?
- Das denke ich auch.
Sie sind sehr natürlich.
Und etwas kurlig.
Das ist ein gutes Wort dafür.
Aber auch immer bereit
für einen Spass.- Schon?
Dann bist du ein guter Finne.
- Ja.
Das ist möglich, ja.
Darum bin ich vielleicht auch hier.
- Ja.
Das Klischee, dass man bei Finnen
für jedes Wort einen Fünfliber
geben muss - stimmt das?
Ja ...
Jenni sagt immer,
wenn meine Verwandtschaft hier sei
oder wir in der Schweiz
und wir ein Essen machen,
würden alle reden,
aber niemand hört zu.
In Finnland hören alle zu
und niemand redet.
* Sie spricht finnisch. *
Sie sagt, der Finne
könne auch einfach ruhig sein,
wenn er nichts zu sagen hat.
- Das geht an unsere Adresse.
* Ächzen *
Im Haus von Dörigs hängt ein Spruch:
"Das Glück kommt nicht,
wenn man es sucht,
sondern wenn man es lebt."
Die Finnen scheinen
besonders gut darin zu sein:
Zum fünften Mal hintereinander
wurden sie zum glücklichsten Volk
der Welt erkoren.
* Entspannte Gitarrenmusik *
"Auf und davon" - auf grosser Tour
durch den hohen Norden.
Ich bin reich beschenkt
mit einem ganzen Blumenstrauss
aus Eindrücken und Geschichten.
Ich kann die Faszination für diese
Landschaft hier oben im hohen Norden
komplett nachvollziehen.
Aber noch mehr beeindruckt haben mich
die Begegnungen mit den Menschen,
die hier oben für sich
das richtige Leben gefunden haben.
Aber ein Treffen, eine
solche Begegnung, steht noch aus.
Darauf freue ich mich speziell.
Erinnert ihr euch an die Hochzeits-
einladung von Andrea und Günther?
Wir haben Andrea
schon im gelben Übergewand
auf der Ölplattform gesehen
und im Sporttenue auf dem Rennvelo.
Jetzt erleben wir sie
bald auch noch im Hochzeitskleid.
Mein Weg
führt mich zurück nach Norwegen,
eine Autostunde von Oslo entfernt.
Die Hochzeit
findet unter freiem Himmel statt.
Mit Aussicht auf einen Fjord.
* Sie sprechen norwegisch. *
"Triff uns bei der Coiffeuse",
liessen mir Andrea und ihre Schwester
ausrichten.
Hallo zusammen.
- Hallo.- Hallo.
Ihr seid schon mittendrin.
Hoi, Andrea.
- Hoi, Mona.
So schön, dich zu sehen.
- Gleichfalls.
Hi, I'm Mona. Nice to meet you.
Sabrina.- Hoi, Mona.
Wie geht es dir?
- Etwas nervös.
Wie viel ist "etwas nervös"?
Schwierig zu sagen.
Im Moment geht es.
Es gibt ja Frauen, die sich
ca. ein Jahr darauf vorbereiten.
Mit Kleider aussuchen, Haarstil usw.
Was hast du alles
für die Vorbereitung gemacht?
Wir haben Ende Januar mal geschaut.
Wir kamen
ins erste Brautkleidergeschäft
und sie meinte, wir seien spät dran,
wegen der Lieferungszeiten.
Dann ist man in den Geschäften
und es heisst,
man müsse probieren,
bis man das Gefühl hat, das sei es.
Bei mir
ist das Gefühl nie aufgekommen.
Wir hatten
zwei ziemlich unterschiedliche.
Eines hatte mehr Spitze
und war eher prinzessinnenmässig.
Das gefiel mir gut, aber ich
entschied mich für das einfache.
Mal schauen,
wie das heute dann aussieht.
Meinst du, Günther kennt mich noch?
* Lachen *
Nein.
Doch, doch.
Bräutigam Günther Greck muss sich
nicht gross um seine Frisur kümmern.
Ja, ich merke gerade,
dass die Anspannung etwas ansteigt.
Ich muss die Unterschrift
mit meinem neuen Namen üben.
Ich muss mich mega konzentrieren.
* Entspannte Musik *
Jetzt ziehe ich das Kleid an.
Jetzt musst du den noch umbinden.
Bitte schön.
- Eng oder nicht?
So ist gut.
Das passt schon mal.
Es sieht schön aus,
wenn du es hältst.
Doch, das geht. Beim Walzer.
Beim Tango bin ich nicht sicher.
* Sie sprechen norwegisch. *
Eine ganz andere Frau als ich
normalerweise im Spiegel sehe.
Das bist auch du.
- Ja.
Wow.
- Nimmst du mich so mit?- Sicher.
* Romantische Klaviermusik *
* Er spricht norwegisch. *
Darum frage ich Sie,
Andrea Nina Eugster:
Sind Sie gewillt,
mit Günther Greck in einer Ehe
auf der Grundlage von Zusammensein
und Respekt zu leben?
Ja.
- Günther Greck:
Sind Sie gewillt,
mit Andrea Eugster zusammen zu sein
und in gegenseitigem Respekt
zu leben?- Ja.
Tauschen Sie bitte die Ringe aus.
* Romantische Musik *
* Jubel und Applaus *
Ich gratuliere euch ganz herzlich.
Alles, alles Gute.
Danke vielmals.
- Günther, alles Gute.
Schön, dass du hier warst.
- Ja.
Dass es geklappt hat.
- Es war sehr schön.
Und jetzt?
- Jetzt wird gefeiert.
Und danach?
Gibt es Flitterwochen? Was macht ihr?
Meine sind auf Gullfaks B.
Ich gehe zwei Wochen arbeiten.
- Was?
Jetzt?
- Am Dienstag muss ich wieder.
Deine Flitterwochen
sind auf der Ölplattform.
Sozusagen. Was Günther dann macht,
weiss ich nicht.
Arbeiten.
Wir gehen,
wenn ich nach Hause komme,
zwei Wochen nach Griechenland.
Ganz uns getreu
haben wir Schwimmferien gebucht.
Wir schwimmen einfach 5 km pro Tag
im griechischen Meer.
Das ist eure Art von Romantik.
- Ja.- Ja.
Auf eine Art, ja.
- Ja.
Beim Apéro sehe ich jemanden,
der mir bekannt vorkommt:
Mein Arbeitskollege Christoph
Siegrist von "SRF Meteo".
Oh, merci. Zum Wohl, Mona.
- Zum Wohl.
Kanntest du Andrea oder deine Frau?
- Meine Frau.
Sie haben zusammen studiert
und sind Freundinnen.
So bist du hierhergekommen.
Aber dass du nach Skandinavien
kommst, ist nicht so selten.
Du bist
einer der grössten Fans beim SRF.
Es ist zwar die falsche Jahreszeit.
Ich gehe im Winter.
Ja, das Nordlicht hat mich gepackt,
aber auch ganz verschiedene Sachen.
Die Landschaft - man hat hier
Weiten, die es bei uns nicht gibt.
Die Lofoten mit den steilen Wänden,
die aus dem Meer herauskomme.
Und für mich natürlich das Wetter.
Das ist hier fantastisch.
Es wechselt von dramatisch
zu schön, dann wieder zu ...
Es geht schnell hier oben.
Den Wetterbericht hier oben
verkünden, wäre das etwas für dich?
Das möchte ich nicht.
Z.B. Norwegen ist länger,
als es breit ist
und das Fernsehen ist breiter,
als es lang ist.
Ah, rein von der Aufteilung her
wird es schwierig.
Da haben wir es
einfacher in der Schweiz.
Auf den hohen Norden.
Ja, auf den hohen Norden.
Und auf das Glück, das er bereit hält
für Menschen wie Andrea und Günther.
Jetzt fehlt nur noch
der lang einstudierte Hochzeitstanz.
* Dramatischer Tango *
* Jubel *
* Jubel und Applaus *
So schön geht sie zu Ende, unsere
grosse Tour durch den hohen Norden.
So offen und herzlich
haben uns die Menschen
hier oben aufgenommen.
Sie haben uns Einblicke gegeben
in ihr Leben und ihre neue Heimat,
weit weg von der Schweiz.
Sie alle sind auf und davon
und angekommen.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022